Wir sehen uns dann bald wieder.
Fürchterlicher Raumklang. Sarah, schönen guten Abend. Chaosradio 48.
Genau, wenn wir uns nicht erzählt haben. Unser Thema heute...
Also letztes Mal war 47, ich werde euch da schon erzählt, aber ansonsten stimmt das. Ich hör schon mal die Musik an, die du mitgebracht hast, Andreas.
Das ist eine gute Sache. Ja, heute haben wir eigentlich zwei Themen. Zwar erst mal ein bisschen was über RPS erzählen, das Reiz-Protection-System. Es geht da um MP3-Filterung. Wir sollen keine MP3s mehr downloaden dürfen. Und aus aktuellem Anlass...
Na eigentlich geht es um was anderes, aber das erklären wir nachher.
Genau, und danach werden wir uns dem Thema digitalem Geld, elektronischem Geld, E-Cash, E-Commerce, na E-Commerce ist ein schlechtes Wort, E-Commerce machen wir nicht. Digitale Zahlungsmittel im Allgemeinen unterhalten. Und was das für Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft, auf die Gesellschaft und so weiter und so fort haben wird.
Tja wunderbar. Im Studio sind übrigens Andreas, Felix, Inge und Pluto.
Nah dran.
Die Klöpfe drückt der Holger, aber das ist heute unwesentlich. Soll ich die Musik was lauter machen und hören? Apex Twin ist das übrigens was der Herr mitgebracht hat.
Ja, RPS ist in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen in News gewesen, aber nicht wirklich breitflächig. Deswegen wollten wir das hier nochmal erwähnen, obwohl das eigentliche Thema der Sendung elektronisches Geld ist. Aber RPS ist schon eine Sache, die wichtig genug ist, um das hier mal ein bisschen eine halbe Stunde lang oder so zu beleuchten. Also es geht prinzipiell darum, dass die Fonoindustrie gerne möchte, dass ihre Margen nicht kleiner werden durch das Internet. Und im Grunde ist ja nicht das Internet allein, sondern auch die CD-Brenner, mit denen man wunderbar Audio-CDs und MP3-CDs machen kann. Und es gibt inzwischen Konsumergeräte, mit denen man MP3-CDs auch wunderbar zu Hause in Stellanlage hören kann. Zum Beispiel so ein DVD-Gerät.
Sag nicht, ich will so eins noch haben, bevor jetzt alle loskommen.
Ja, also das ist irgendwie auch das eins der billigsten DVD-Geräte, die es gibt und auch eins der besten. Ich finde, das kann man ruhig ein bisschen planken. Das kostet irgendwie 500 Mark bei Media am Markt. Ruht euch das.
Man kann den Region-Code abschalten.
Genau, man kann den Region-Code abschalten, man kann Macromedia abschalten, eher Macrovision und man kann seine MP3-CDs brennen. Und letztendlich gibt es halt Studien von der Fonoindustrie, die festgestellt haben, dass hinter die Margen weggehen, weil die Leute irgendwie weniger CDs kaufen. Und das wird, also eigentlich kaufen die Leute nicht weniger CDs, sondern mehr CDs, aber es sind weniger, als die Leute prognostiziert hatten, was die verkaufen würden. Und deswegen schließen sie daraus, dass sie mehr Gewinn hätten machen können, wenn es keine MP3s im Internet gäbe und weniger Leute, die Raubkopien auf CDs machen. Also Raubkopien ist so ein Name, der da ganz gern erwähnt wird. Und eigentlich sind es keine Raubkopien. Das werden wir gleich auch noch klären. Copykills Music. Also die Wahrheit ist, dass es nicht illegal ist, wenn ihr euch zu Hause CDs kopiert von eurem Freund. Es ist allerdings illegal, wenn ihr das dann verkauft. Aber grundsätzlich ist es nicht so, dass es illegal wäre, sich aus dem Internet MP3s zu sorgen und die zu hören, das darf man. Aber das gefällt der Phonoindustrie nicht. Vielleicht sollten wir an der Stelle erwähnen, wer die Phonoindustrie ist. Das ist nämlich nicht die Künstler. Das sind auch nicht die Vertreter der Künstler. Das sind auch nicht die CD-Verkäufer, sondern das sind die Plastikbrenner, die CD-Schweißer. Also die Leute, die am wenigsten daran beteiligt sind, dass Musik gemacht wird, die aber ungefähr die Hälfte der Marge mitnehmen und im Grunde zu Recht den Vertrieb in den Ländern machen.
Also es ist so, dass der Vertrieb pro Land aufgeteilt ist. Das heißt, wer in Deutschland eine CD von Prinz verkauft, darf sie noch lange nicht in den USA verkaufen. Und weil es übers Internet problemlos möglich ist, sich eine CD aus den USA kommen zu lassen, fürchten die halt, dass ihr althergebrachtes System, um sich ihre Freunde zu sichern, wegbrechen wird. Und noch viel schlimmer ist es, wenn man die MP3s direkt übers Netz verkauft, weil dann kann man auch keine Einfüllzölle oder so was mehr erheben. Und deswegen wollen sie jetzt alle MP3s wegfiltern. Da gab es dann bei der TCPIP GmbH einen Feldversuch.
Also vielleicht, wir gehen gleich noch mal in Ruhe auf die Strukturen ein, die sich da aufgebaut haben in der Phonoindustrie, über die im Moment die Kohle da zusammenkommt, weil wenn man das hört, dann versteht man, warum CD's so teuer sind, wo das Geld hinfließt, was damit gemacht wird.
Also ich hab da ja mal vor kurzem jemanden interviewt, der dieses Copykills Music mit angeschoben hat und der meinte, CDs wären gar nicht so teuer. Also als ich gesagt hab, das stimmt, das sind 4, 80 Mark für irgendeine CD, hat er gesagt, das ist gar nicht wahr und kam mit irgendeiner Zahl um die 20 mark, die eine CD im Durchschnitt kostet. Fand ich sehr lächerlich.
Na ja, da kommt dann diese Vansmark, da ist dann die 5 Marks McDonalds CD von das runter. Genau. Nein, aber man muss sagen, letztendlich geht es halt darum, dass die Phonoindustrie denkt, sie wird mehr Geld verdienen, wenn sie MP3s verhindern und haben das also auf mehreren Schienen versucht durchzusetzen. Und eine der Schienen war unter anderem, dass sie versucht haben, das einfach als illegal zu erklären in der Öffentlichkeit. Und es ist auch weit vorgedrungen. Fast alle Leute glauben immer noch, dass illegal ist MP3s zu hören oder dass man die nicht downloaden dürfte oder dass man seinem Freund keine Tapes kopieren dürfte und so. Da stimmt alles nicht, da ist alles egal. Aber das reicht eben der Phonoindustrie noch nicht. Die hätten trotzdem noch mehr Geld. Deswegen haben sie jetzt versucht, gern den Providern, also den Internetdienstleistern, die die Gegenstelle zu eurem Modem darstellen, den Leuten per Gesetz reinzudrücken, dass sie einen Filter installieren müssen, der illegale MP3 wegfällt hat. Nun ist MP3 an sich nicht illegal und deswegen ist diese ganze Definition schlecht. Aber wenn man das so darstellt, als wäre das illegal, dann findet man eher Leute, die bereit sind, so Politiker, die bereit sind, eben damit zu machen. Und tatsächlich läuft das im Moment so, dass die Phonoindustrie den Politikern erzählt, dass das illegal ist, MP3 aus dem Internet zu sorgen und dass man deswegen verhindern muss, dass die Leute das tun in ihrem eigenen Interesse, weil die würden sich ja sonst strafbar machen. Und die Filterarchitektur, die sich da überlegt haben, ist technisch tatsächlich machbar, dass ist auch weswegen wir da überhaupt beteiligt sind, weil uns das eben aufgefallen ist, als einer der ersten Zensur- und Filterversuche, die tatsächlich technisch machbar werden. Grundsätzlich war es uns bisher...
Uneingeschränkt technisch machbar, also wenn ich statt MP3 jetzt Punkt Dock nenne...
Es gibt da zwei Kriterien, unter denen man technische Machbarkeit sehen kann. Und zwar das System, was sie da hingebaut haben, ist im Wesentlichen ein Proxy, ein Zwangs-Proxy, an dem man nicht vorbeikommt, der bestimmte URLs einfach sperrt. Und dieses Konzept bestimmte URLs zu sperren, das funktioniert technisch natürlich. Das funktioniert natürlich nicht in dem Sinne, dass es MP3-Kopieren verhindert, weil erstens taucht das Ding jede Stunde unter einer anderen URL auf, zweitens gibt es Möglichkeiten, das auch nicht über HTTP, sondern über andere Protokolle auszutauschen. Also zum Beispiel hat Napster ja viel Schlagzeilen gemacht in letzter Zeit.
Und zurecht, also die Hälfte des Internet-Traffics von US-Unis ist im Durchschnitt so mit Napster im Moment belegt. Also selbst wenn, also man muss ja so sagen, wir sind so teilweise Informatiker hier, das heißt, wenn wir sagen, es funktioniert, dann meinen wir nicht, es löst das Problem, sondern es funktioniert entsprechend den Specks. Also das heißt, es gibt immer am Anfang eine Definition, was so ein Ding leisten soll und in diesem Fall soll es eben leisten, dass bestimmte URLs gesperrt sind. Und das lässt sich machen. Und das ist auch implementiert worden jetzt. Also es gibt jetzt einen Test Provider, nämlich die TCP IPG in Berlin. Die hat einen solchen Proxy installiert. Proxy ist ein schwieriges Wort, kennt kaum jemand. Das heißt im Grunde, dass wenn man in seinem Browser irgendwas anklickt, ohne dass man daran was tun könnte, wird das dann bearbeitet. Das sehen Leute, die Freenet benutzen oder so schon länger, weil die erste URL, die man da immer sieht, egal wo man hinsurfen will, ist irgendwie die Homepage von Freenet. Das gibt es schon eine Weile. Diese Sachen funktionieren auch. Und jetzt gibt es eben einen Testversuch, wo die Leute von sich selbst URLs eingetragen haben in so einem Filter und haben die dann versucht anzusurfen und dann festgestellt Ja, die sind geblockt worden. Und aufgrund von diesem Test kann man jetzt behaupten, dass Filterung möglich wäre, was auch stimmt. Man kann filtern, aber es löst das Problem nicht. Das Problem ist jetzt einfach, dass im Moment das Filtern deswegen noch nicht von den Internetprovidern verlangt wird, weil es als unzumutbar gilt. Es gibt da eine gesetzliche Regelung, dass der Internetprovider für den Inhalt, den die User bei ihm gucken, nicht zuständig ist, außer er wird explizit darauf hingewiesen, dass es an dieser einen Stelle illegalen Content gibt. Und es ist ihm zumutbar, dass er den dann wegfiltert. Und bisher ist eben die landläufige Meinung gewesen, dass es nicht zumutbar ist, von dem Internetprovider zu verlangen, dass er wegfiltert. Aber das könnte sich eben mit einer konzertierten PR-Aktion aufgrund von diesem Versuch jetzt ändern. Und deswegen sind wir da angesprungen und haben auch mal mit der TCP-IP geredet, was sie sich dann darunter vorstellen und so. Und die eigentliche Gefahr ist eigentlich gar nicht, es geht gar nicht um MP3s bei der Sache. Also vielleicht geht es ja vor eine Industrie um MP3s. Aber wenn eine solche Struktur in der Lage ist, MP3s rauszufiltern, dann kann sie natürlich auch andere Sachen rausfiltern. Und interessant ist an der Stelle natürlich, wer sich da so als erstes auf so einen Zug aufwirft. Und in diesem Fall war das das Bundeskriminalamt. Die haben gesagt, na dann filtern wir auch gleich Nazi-Kram raus. Und dann ist das Finanzamt gekommen und hat gesagt, ja wir würden gerne Steuer auf E-Commerce erheben. Und haben sich da auch gleich draufgesprungen. Also das Problem ist einfach, es ist hier kurz davor, dass eine Infrastruktur im Internet entsteht. Das ist einfach eine Infrastruktur, gegen die keiner mehr was tun kann. Wenn erstmal jeder ISP so ein Proxy hat, was im Moment noch nicht ist. Also wir sind noch nicht so weit, aber es ist kurz davor. Wenn jeder Internet Provider so ein Proxy hat, wo bestimmte URLs gesperrt sind, dann können Stellen ohne dem User das überhaupt sichtbar zu machen, Sachen sperren und verändern. Es geht nicht nur darum, dass man die Sachen sperren kann, sondern man kann auch subtile Änderungen machen. Also es ist technisch genauso drin, dass man, wenn man zu Spiegel surft, dann eben nicht nur den Spiegel sieht, sondern andere Werbung einblendet, als der Spiegel da einblenden möchte. Ja, also es sind so weitgehende Veränderungen drin und es wäre auch drin, dass man irgendwelchen unliebsamen, politisch nicht geneigten Sites irgendwelche illegalen Content unterschiebt und die daraufhin verknackt. Also das sind einfach Mittel, die hier technisch realisierbar wären, wenn diese Infrastruktur geschaffen würde, die uns auf keinen Fall gefallen und die wir gerne der Öffentlichkeit jemanden mal näher bringen wollen. Das sind Sachen, die uns drohen. Und die Gefahr ist einfach, dass der User im Moment, die nicht den Wert eines ungefilterten Internets nicht so sieht, das möchten wir gerne kommunizieren, dass es wichtig ist für den User, dass er nicht lauwarmes Internet kriegt, sondern ein richtiges Internet und dass ein Unterschied ist zwischen Web und Internet. Viele Leute glauben, wenn sie zur OR gehen und Internet bestellen, dann kriegen sie da einmal webklicken.
Das ist ja auch dann schon gefiltert.
Das ist auch gefiltert. Genau. Deswegen sagen wir das. Also es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Web und Internet. Und wenn ihr zu einem Internetprovider geht, dann solltet ihr darauf auch Wert legen, dass ihr da Internet kriegt und nicht nur Web. Und das mit dem Filtern, wir arbeiten daran. Aber wenn ihr was Gutes tun wollt, dann geht mal zu einem Internetprovider und fragt ihn, ob ihr eigentlich filtert und ob er das gut findet und macht ihm klar, dass ihr sofort wechselt, wenn er filtert und am besten auch ohne euch das zu sagen. Und man muss ja auch sagen, der eigentliche Feind in diesem Fall ist gar nicht die Fundeindustrie, weil diese Infrastruktur, wer weiß schon, wer die dann kontrolliert. Ja, es geht ja letztlich darum, die Hardware wäre da und die ISPs, da stehen sie dann im Keller, die hätten vielleicht Zugriff. Aber es gibt da so ein anderes Gesetz, was an der Stelle ganz bekannt ist, nämlich was die ISPs dazu zwingt, eine Wartungs Hintertür für die Polizei einzurichten und für gewisse schattige Dienste der Bundesregierung, Geheimdienste. Und dieser Wartungszugang soll eigentlich benutzt werden können und um im Zweifelsfall in kriminalistischen Ermittlungen Beweise zu sammeln. Aber das heißt eben auch dieser Zugang soll laut Gesetz auch so sein, dass der Internet Provider nicht mitkriegt, ob der Zugang gerade benutzt wird. Das heißt, in Zusammenarbeit mit dieser Proxy Infrastruktur wäre es denkbar, dass die Regierung oder wer weiß wer, die Kontrolle ist einfach nicht da an der Stelle, den Usern deutschlandweit irgendwelche Seiten vorenthält. Und das ist transparent möglich, sodass weder der User noch die Site merkt, dass sein Filter dazwischen ist.
Ja und vor allem, wenn das merken würde, wäre es illegal, ne?
Dazu musst du näher ans Mikrofon rangehen, um das sagen zu können.
Genau, halt mal nicht so vor, ein bisschen näher.
Du bist eins von den Harmschweinen, die kein Headset haben.
Naja, das Problem ist, wenn es doch merken würde, wäre es illegal.
Das wäre illegal zu merken, dass er...
Er darf es ja nicht merken, wenn sich irgendwelche staatlichen Stellen zur Überwachung seiner wichtigen Daten mal einklicken. Wenn er es dann doch merkt, dann hat er sich ja entgegen der Abmachung verhalten.
Also die Gesetzgebung ist sehr obskur, teilweise gar nicht durchsetzbar. Und im Grunde, die Fondueindustrie weiß, unserer Meinung nach, auch gar nicht, was sie da gerade einrichtet. Das ist unsere Befürchtung an der Sache.
Das wird dir egal sein.
Ja, das kommt auch so ein bisschen dazu.
Wir haben jetzt Ehre oder so.
Wir haben jetzt die TCP IP gehen. Wir haben mal gefragt, warum sie das tut und wie sie das dann finden und haben so ein bisschen befürchtet, die TCP IP spielt sich da so als Bösewicht auf oder sie wollen das vielleicht oder letztendlich wussten wir auch nicht genau, wer jetzt eigentlich hinter der Sache steckt und wie viel da dran ist. Aber es stellt sich eben raus, die TCP IP möchte, das kann ich machen, weil sie gerne die Leute gefiltert haben möchte, sondern die TCP IP möchte eben gerne der Phonoe-Industrie gegenüber als Internetpartner auftreten, sich positionieren. Und die TCP IP hat auch gar keine Privatkunden, die sich da einwählen, die das betreffen würde. Deswegen können die das auch mal kurz machen. Und so stellt sich das eben da, dass es zwar nur ein kleiner Schritt ist und es war auch noch keiner betroffen, weil die keine Kunden haben, die da gefiltert wurden und es ist auch noch kein Zwangsproxy bisher. Aber die Möglichkeiten werden eben geschaffen. Und wenn man sich so totalitäre Regimes ansieht in der Vergangenheit und irgendwelche Sachen gegen die Menschenrechte, dass es selten schlagartig passiert, sondern es ist immer so schrittweise, es baut sich langsam auf. Und im Moment sieht es eben für uns so aus, als wenn sich da so potentiell was aufbaut und es liegt uns was daran, das zu kommunizieren.
Natürlich wird genauso wie bei der ganzen Kameraüberwachung und so weiter und sofort großer Lauschangriff hoch und teilig beteuert, dass dann natürlich nur unter demokratischer Kontrolle und in besonderen Fällen diese Mittel gebraucht werden. Aber die Vergangenheit hat einfach gezeigt, dass wenn Mechanismen existieren, die totalitäre Kontrolle erlauben, dann werden sie früher oder später auch missbraucht von irgendjemandem, der dann halt mal in dieser Position sitzt. Und die Tatsache, dass da heute vielleicht Leute sitzen, die vertrauenswürdig sind, heißt noch lange nicht, dass da morgen immer noch Leute sitzen, die vertrauenswürdig sind. Deshalb sollte man gar nicht erst anfangen, solche Technologien aufzusetzen.
Na und man muss sagen, die Fondindustrie ist ja keine staatliche Einrichtung und ist auch kein Non-Profit-Unternehmen, sondern das Ziel der phonographischen Industrie ist die Profitmaximierung wie bei allen Firmen. Und das heißt letztendlich, wenn sie da Daten sammeln, es geht auch nicht nur um Zensieren, sondern es geht darum, dass man auch alles mithören kann, natürlich was durch so ein Proxy geht. Also man kann sehen, welcher User wann was guckt, welche Seiten angucken, man kann wunderbare Profile erstellen, man kann sehen, wer schwul ist und wer nicht. Ja, so eine Sachen, da lassen sich wunderbar Daten sammeln und die sind in den Händen von einer Vereinigung, die explizit so ein Ziel hat, Geld zu machen.
Naja, jetzt könnte man der Regierung unterstellen, dass sie auch nichts anderes tut als Leuten, die profitorientiert sind, Unterstützung zukommen zu lassen.
Ja, na gut, aber bei der Regierung gibt es Gesetze, Datenschutzgesetz ist der Regierung gegenüber sehr unangenehm, den Firmen gegenüber sehr zurückhaltend, weil als es gemacht wurde, war eben das Ziel zu verhindern, dass die Regierung irgendwelche schlimmen Daten sammelt. Das heißt, wir haben einfach das Problem, dass diese Vereinigung nicht irgendwelchen öffentlichen Gremien, es gibt keine Mechanismen, die das regulieren würden. Das heißt, wenn die sich entscheiden, einfach eine Sache mehr zu sperren, dann gibt es keinen öffentlichen Weg, über den man da Protest einlegen könnte. Die sind keinem anderen Gremium Rechenschaft schuldig. Das ist einfach das Problem. Wir wollen gar nicht unterstellen, dass es böse Verräter sind, die Deutschland in den Abgrund stürzen wollen, aber die Möglichkeiten, die sich auftun, sind sehr bedenklich.
Als Beispiel für ein Land, wo das schon passiert ist, Singapur, da gibt es eine Mauer rund um die gesamte Stadt, eine Firewall, wo Zwangsproxies und Filterungen laufen. Und so was kann uns mit dem System auch in Deutschland wohnen, weil das nicht nur bei den einzelnen Providern eingesetzt werden soll, sondern bei allen Providern, die eine Leitung ins Ausland haben. Das ist noch so der Gag an der Sache, dass im Prinzip so 70 Providere oder so sollen sein, die eine Leitung nach außen haben und dass die dann weggefiltert werden, dass im Prinzip jeder, der sich nach Ansicht irgendwelcher Industrien staf gemacht haben sollte, hier innerhalb von Deutschland sitzt und alle anderen von außerhalb ausgesperrt werden.
Also das witzige ist ja auch die Argumentation, die benutzt wurde, um diese Infrastruktur aufzubauen. Denn ursprünglich wurde gesagt, es geht nur um eine Art voll. Also das ging darum, dass die Argumentation war die, dass man sagt, im Moment ist es schon so, wenn irgendjemand mp3s oder cds aus dem Ausland importiert, dann wird das rechtmäßig der Phonindustrie zustehende Geld laut ihrer Meinung nach durch den Zoll eingezogen und es gibt halt im Internet keinen Zoll. Das heißt, ihre Argumentation war, sie möchten jetzt gerne ein Zoll im Internet etablieren, den weil den der Staat nicht eingerichtet, müssten sie da eben vorbrechen. Und das war so die die Argumentation und letztendlich, wenn man sich das anhört, klingt das ja auch so, als wenn die eigentlich recht haben und als wenn es da moralisch ihre Verpflichtung wäre, den armen Todler in den Künstlern Geld zukommen zu lassen. Aber man sollte vielleicht an der Stelle deutlich betonen, dass das Geld nicht zum Künstler geht, was da eingenommen wird, sondern das bleibt bei der Fundindustrie natürlich.
Betonen was nachher, machen wir noch ein bisschen Musik, dann Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Ja toll, jetzt hat hier David an der Emoderung gespielt und jetzt ist das Infobett weg. Ich könnte heulen. Es ist immer wieder das selbe. 22 Uhr 31 Minuten.
Nazi-Überfall dem Erlienetagespiegel zufolge haben Rechtsextreme im brandenburgischen Rietzen eine Hetzjagd auf linksgerichtete Jugendliche veröbt. Dabei wurde ein 14-jähriger lebensgefährlich verletzt. Der Vorfall ereignete sich bereits am 10.
März.
Drei Neonazis sollen inzwischen verhaftet worden sein. Rückzug. Im Verkehrsverbund Berlin Brandenburg wird es zum 1. April keine Tariferhöhung geben. Der Aufsichtsrat wird am 12. April über Höhe und Zeitpunkt einer Tarifanpassung entscheiden. In den nächsten 14 Tagen soll auch ein Beschluss zu den Fahrkarten für den Berliner C-Bereich fallen. Abbau. Die Deutsche Bahn will im Rahmen ihres massiven Personalabbaus auch bei den Ausbildungsplätzen sparen. Einem Sprecher zufolge wird die Bahn in diesem Jahr etwa 1000 Lehrlinge weniger einstellen als 1999. Ergebnislos die Tarifverhandlung für die 3, 1 Millionen Beschäftigten des öffentlichen Dienstes sind am Abend ohne Annäherung auf den 14. April vertagt worden. Die Gewerkschaften fordern 5 Prozent mehr Lohn und eine Angleichung der Osttarife.
Sport.
Eine Meldung vom Fußball, das Testländerspiel. Kroatien, Deutschland endete eins zu eins.
Wette.
In der Nacht bis 3 Grad, morgen gelegentlich Regen bis 10 Grad.
Entschuldigung, Fritz Kursel von mit Nicole Markwald. Vielen Dank und nix für ungut.
Also wir haben vor wenigen Tagen darüber gesprochen bei uns in der Lastung.
Scheiße, jetzt geht das schon wieder los.
Mit Ingolf Lück.
Anke Engelke.
Hallo liebe Liebende.
Markus Maria Profitling. Samstag 27.
Mai in der Waldbühne. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Andreas, ja mal drum, dann machen wir das mit einer Leise.
Ja, schon wieder der selbe Song, das geht ja nicht.
Ja, das sehe ich, ist nur einer drauf.
Ja, deswegen ist das Chaos Radio.
Das ist neu.
Schon besser.
Echt?
Ja, also mit RPS waren wir glaube ich soweit fast fertig.
Genau, wir hatten dann noch ein paar Referenzen offen, meinte einer unserer Bitchstrakter.
Ich wollte was sagen zur Fonoindustrie.
Was wollt ihr zur Fonoindustrie noch was sagen?
Genau, die Fonoindustrie. Und zwar ist es da ja so, dass es da verschiedene Schritte gibt. Also da gibt es irgendwo den armen hungerlandenden Künstler, der Musik macht.
Genau.
Und dann geht er damit zu einem Label und dieses Label produziert dann eine Platte. Und diese wiederum wird dann von einem Vertrieb in verschiedenen Ländern verkauft. Das war diese Geschichte, wo dann für jedes Land jemand anders die Rechte hat, einen Vertrieb zu machen. Und dann gibt es dann irgendwo den Plattenladen, wo ich meine Platte kaufen kann. Also insgesamt gibt es da fünf Entitäten, die dabei verdienen. Und wenn jetzt die durch das Internet im Prinzip der mittlere Schritt wegfällt, wenn die Zwischenhändler wegfallen und jetzt anfangen rum zu jammern, dass sie da wenn ihr Geld verdienen, dass die armen Künstler darunter leiden, dann ist das ja eigentlich nicht wahr. Sondern die Künstler können ja nach wie vor Geld verdienen, nur dass die Platte direkter verkauft wird, auf einem kürzeren Wege unter Umgehung dieser Zwischenhändler.
Na auch die Labels, also die eigentliche Diskussion war ja immer, wie sie dargestellt wurde, dass die Labels die armen wären, dass man die Labels ausschalten wollten würde und dass die Künstler direkt MP3s machen. So ist das ja nicht. Denn die Labels sind ja letztendlich die, die die Infrastruktur für den Künstler finanzieren, das Studium, in dem er seine Sachen aufnimmt. Und die Labels werden nach wie vor gebraucht werden. Keine Frage. Also die Labels sind auch gar nicht die, die durch MP3 obsolet gemacht werden. Im Gegenteil, die können nämlich MP3s auf ihrem Server tun.
Aber die, die sich jetzt hinstellen und rumbrullen, hier so Copykills, Music und so weiter, das sind ja gar nicht die Labels. Das ist ja der Vertrieb. Und da sind wir auch schon fast beim Thema unserer Sendung, weil momentan ist es ja so, da holt man sich die MP3s von irgendwelchen Pirate-Servern oder von Napster. Aber genauso gut könnte ein Künstler hingehen, könnte die MP3s auf seiner Webseite verkaufen. Nur, dass es relativ teuer ist, momentan z.B. Kreditkarten zu akzeptieren auf dem Internet. Also so das, was man für einen Song bezahlen würde, so die 50 bis 70 Pfennig, das lohnt sich einfach nicht als Kreditkartentransaktion.
Na, das lohnt sich schon. Also man muss vielleicht mal das Finanzierungsmodell der Kreditkartengesellschaft...
Ja, lass uns das mal irgendwie... Also es ist zu teuer. Effektiv kannst du keine 50 Pfennig, erst einen anderen Punkt, die Kreditkarten spielen.
Nein, aber das liegt im Grunde daran, dass die Kreditkartengesellschaft pro, die verdienen prozentual an jedem Gekauften, an jeder Rechnung und sie verdienen auch Pauschal insgesamt. Und der Pauschalbetrag macht es erst, also es gibt so eine Monatspauschale, was man ihm abdrückt und die macht Transaktionen nur ab 5 Mark ungefähr sinnvoll.
Genau, und außerdem sind Kreditkarten sowieso böse, weil sie eine Datenspur hinterlassen und weil es geborgtes Geld ist und man dann ruckzuck Schulden angehäuft hat und so weiter und so fort. Also insgesamt sind die Zahlungsmittel übers Internet noch nicht wirklich attraktiv dafür Musik tatsächlich zu verkaufen. Und wenn das aber da ist, wenn man in der Lage ist, als Künstler einfach einen MP3 auf seine Webseite zu packen, dafür 50 Pfennig zu nehmen, ohne großen Aufwand, ohne dicke Verträge unterschreiben zu müssen, dann wird plötzlich der Vertrieb gar nicht mehr gebraucht und fällt weg. Es wird für den End-User, den der die Musik hört, billiger werden und dadurch wird der Künstler im Endeffekt eigentlich auch mehr Geld verdienen als mit der CD, weil da so viel wegfällt. Und von dem, was der Anwender weniger zahlt, was der Musikhörer weniger zahlt, bleibt trotzdem mehr hinterher für den Künstler übrig. Und insofern ist mp3 schon auch noch eine Perspektive für die Künstler. Nicht wie zum Beispiel bei dieser Initiative Copic Hills Music behauptet wird, eine Gefahr für die Künstler.
Man muss sich natürlich überlegen, wer macht welche Statements aus welcher Perspektive heraus und die Distributoren sehen sich schon von der sehr realen Gefahr, dass sie im Prinzip überflüssig sind.
Ja, aber dann sollen sie doch bitte schön sagen Copic Hills Income oder sonst irgendwas. Und nicht Copic Hills Music, weil das ist gelogen.
Ach, das kann man sonst sagen. Das ist doch nur eine angepasste Realität.
Ich kann versuchen dieses Interview aus dem Archiv zu krammen, weil der hat sich sowas von verstammelt und verhaspelt und hat am Ende selber zugegeben, dass alles schmuh ist, was da da dran steht. Das war wirklich köstlich. Vier und halb Minuten, wir haben uns kaputt gelacht hinterher.
Man sollte vielleicht auch mal sagen, wie das mit den CDs funktioniert, weil letztendlich ist ja so, dass es sich heute für eine richtig kleine, für einen richtig kleinen Künstler, der irgendwie, sagen wir, 1000 Fans hat, lohnt es sich nicht, CDs rauszubringen, weil CD-Pressen lohnt sich erst ab Stückzahlen von 10.000, denn die CDs zu pressen kostet zwar nur zwei Mark, inklusive wunderbar bedruckt und Papier drin und so, aber dazu muss man einen pressfähigen Rolling erstellen und das kostet 10.000 Mark, deswegen lohnt sich das nicht für kleine Stückzahlen und an der Stelle macht MP3 tatsächlich einen Unterschied, weil Leute, die nur ein paar hundert Fans haben, können per MP3 für keine Kosten im Grunde mit ihrem privat gekauften Equipment zu Hause ein bisschen Musik aufnehmen und als MP3 verkaufen und im Moment ist es so, dass Künstler darauf angewiesen sind, irgendein Label zu finden, das ihnen freiwillig eben ein Studio finanziert und Aufnahmen macht und das sind Investitionen von Labelseute, so in Höhe von 50.000 aufwärts, die eben der Künstler auch dann nicht aufbringen muss und auch nicht kann im Grunde, weil kleine Künstler haben halt kein Geld, deswegen MP3 ist schon gut für die Künstler.
Man muss auf der anderen Seite natürlich sagen, dass sich damit wirklich auch das gesamte Modell der Branche vollkommen ändert. Es geht ja nicht nur darum, dass einfach hier mal ein ganzer Teil der Wertschönskette vollkommen wegfällt. Ups, das gefällt dem Teil aber gar nicht, wenn er plötzlich wegfällt. Vor allem, wo er doch gestern gerade noch so schön zu Mittag gegessen hat. Vor allem ist es auch aus Kunden sich natürlich eine ganz andere Sache. Bis jetzt werden ja nur Bundles verkauft, die ich im Zweifelsfall gar nicht haben will. Warum muss ich denn immer ein ganzes Album kaufen zum Beispiel, wo doch jeder weiß, dass da nur ein Stück drauf gut ist?
Entschuldigung, bist du Wirtschaftswissenschaftler?
Naja, aber warum muss ich ja eine ganze CD kaufen, wenn so nur ein Stück drauf ist, ne?
Es geht ja noch weiter, der Künstler selbst könnte ja, im Moment kommt ein Großteil der Ausgaben für die Labels daher, dass sie kleine unbekannte Künstler mal kurz pushen und aus denen wird dann nichts. Es wird aus wenigen Künstlern was, die bringen richtig viel Kohle ein und mit denen wird der kleine Künstler so fensioniert. Und deswegen sind die Labels eben auf der Suche nach Künstlern, die sie ein bisschen pushen können. Und deswegen muss der Künstler von sich aus gucken, wie er die Labels auf sich aufmerksam macht und so. Das verursacht alles Kosten. Und wenn jetzt die kleinen Künstler nicht Labels sich suchen müssen, sondern sich auf etwas in der Garage mit ihrem Home Hi-Fi Equipment bei MP3s aufnehmen und ins Internet tun, dann ist das nicht nur für den Künstler besser, sondern auch den Labels entgehen diese Investitionen, die alle floppen. Also letztendlich ist es so, dass die Labels sich nur noch die Kirschen rauspicken können aus den MP3s im Internet und dann die, von denen sie wissen, dass sie erfolgreich sind, pushen können. Also letztendlich heißt es auch, dass Musik einfach billiger wird, wenn man sie auf CD kauft.
Wobei sich natürlich letztendlich auch an einen gewissen Teil der Labelkosten einfach auf die Suchkosten verschiebt und es dann halt die Frage ist, wie die Position nämlich in der richtigen großen, weltweiten MP3-Suchmaschine am Geschackt ist.
Okay, wollten wir noch was erklären?
Ich glaube mittlerweile können wir zur ähm, genau.
Da haben wir eigentlich auch gleich eine gute Überleitung zum nächsten Thema, weil, wie jetzt gesagt wurde, man kann den Zwischenhandel ausschalten. Man kann da draußen, jeder kleine Musiker kann seine eigenen MP3s direkt übers Internet verkaufen, er kann sie da anbieten, er kann sich damit sein Studio finanzieren und seine Miete zahlen und so weiter. Da stellt sich halt die Frage, wie geht denn das? Weil irgendwie Geld und Internet und irgendwie alles unsicher und wollen wir überhaupt Geld im Internet? Und das wird dann gleich nach der nächsten Musik das Thema für die nächsten anderthalb Stunden.
Björn, kannst du mal gerade Geld definieren?
Ich wusste, irgendjemand wollte mich reinlegen heute.
Ja, haben wir nicht gesagt, dass du ein Hardtop bist. Ich kann auch einfach dein Mikro ausmachen, solange du tippst. Da sind wir wieder, Chaosradio 48, worum soll es gehen nochmal?
Geld. Muscheln.
Also nicht Muscheln selber, sondern Muschel-Äquivalente. Also etwas, was so aussieht, als ob jemand anders einem glauben würde, dass er dafür etwas kriegt, wenn man das jetzt einem gibt. So im Sinne von also ein generelles Tauschmittel für halt, ich kann was und mach was für dich, dafür gibst du mir was, was ich bei jemanden anders wieder einlösen kann.
Ja, eigentlich war früher alles viel besser.
Dann ist doch irgendwie über Geld im Internet zu reden relativ müßig, weil das gibt es doch schon im Internet.
Na ja, Schweine transportieren ist so unheimlich.
Also früher war das ja eigentlich viel schöner, wo man halt gegen die Kuh vom Nachbarn hat, man halt die Ziege getauscht und so weiter und so fort. Und dann der einzige Grund, warum wir überhaupt darüber reden, ist halt das Problem, dass Ziegen heutzutage und auch Kühe allerdings halt echt schlecht durch die Modemleitungen passen. Da brauchen wir halt richtig große Bandreiten für und deswegen halt die ganze Geschichte mit elektronischem Geld. Also im Prinzip geht es um den Austausch von irgendwelchen abstrakten Werteinheiten zwischen mindestens zwei Personen. Hier fangen wir gleich schon die Komplexitäten an. Es sollten nämlich tendenziell deutlich mehr als zwei Personen sein, damit die Etablierung eines Geldsystems überhaupt Sinn macht. Und was ist das Tolle an Geld? Erstens ist es vollkommen abstrakt. Also ich habe eine abstrakte Verrechnungseinheit für Dienstleistungen, Kuhhälften, Schweinehälften, was auch immer. Und außerdem ist das Tolle, wenn ich halt ganz, ganz viele Leute habe, die alle diese gleichen Muschel-Äquivalente haben, dann stellt sich nämlich die Frage, kann ich eigentlich auch mal was bezahlen, ohne dass dann jeder gleich weiß, dass ich halt... Anonymität. Genau. Normalerweise, wenn man halt mit der Kuh vom Herrn Müller immer direkt um die Ecke kommt, weiß jeder, hat der mal wieder da bezahlt, damit er mal wieder da eine schöne... Wissen schon, ne? Und das Tolle an Geld ist eigentlich das Anonymen. Also einer der vielen schönen Dinge an Geld. Und das haben wir bis jetzt noch nicht. Wenn wir im Internet was bezahlen wollen, also hatten wir bis jetzt noch nicht, ich korrigiere mich. Kreditkarte, klar, man verlässt immer sehr schön eine lange, schleimige Datenspur, nicht nur das Kreditinstitut sofort. Aha, der Herr, Frau sowieso hat also dieses jene Seuchte getan, sehr interessante Kaufangewohnheiten. Und das will man eigentlich nicht auf verschiedenen Gründen.
Also Stichwort der anonyme Umschlag, wie heißt das immer, der diskrete Verpackung. Genau, diskrete Verpackung, also letztendlich wird der Beflucht.
Also eigentlich der Parteispenden-Skandal ist eigentlich die Grundfürdetung.
Das ist auch das Ziel bei der ersten Definition von elektronischem Geld gewesen, wie kann ich Parteispenden und Drogenkauf so machen, dass keiner zuguckt.
Du meinst Drogen von Parteispenden? Also das haben sie Ihnen bis jetzt noch nicht unterstellt.
Das kriegen wir auch noch hin. Zumindest die Tabakindustrie, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Also eigentlich geht es darum, wie kann ich Werte über das Internet übermitteln, wenn doch jedes Kind weiß, dass im Internet nur mit 0 und 1 Daten übertragen werden und wenn ein Geldschein als Daten repräsentierbar wäre, denkt man sich, das kopiere ich dann einfach und zahlt zweimal damit. Das ist so der erste Einwand, den man sich so naiv macht, wenn man sich Geld im Internet vorstellt. Und tatsächlich, das ist eins der Probleme, die es da gibt. Ein anderes Problem ist natürlich die Anonymität und das ist tatsächlich alles sehr schwierig zu lösen. Und es hat einige größere Innovationen in der Kryptographie, der Datenverschlüsselung, der Wissenschaft der Verschlüsselung erfordert, um ein Protokoll zu entwickeln, was tatsächlich die Anforderungen erfüllt, die man so hat.
Wenn wir uns mal angucken, was momentan im Internet benutzt wird, um damit zu bezahlen, dann sind das in der Regel Kreditkarten. Gelegentlich findet man auch mal Versuche, so was wie die Geldkarte oder Mondex in Großbritannien und so weiter sofort zu bezahlen, einzusetzen.
Mondex?
Mondex ist im Prinzip dasselbe wie die Geldkarte, von der Technologie her.
Ist in Großbritannien, deswegen kennst du es nicht.
Vermutlich.
Ja und in Afrika, das haben da gerade 17 Staaten irgendwie.
Ja, in den Benelux Staaten läuft dasselbe System unter dem Namen Proton. Also es wird überall natürlich inkompatibel, prima für die EU, gerade versucht einzuführen und die haben sich um das Problem der kopierbaren Daten nicht wirklich hinreichend gekümmert, sondern da ist das Geld auf der Chipkarte gespeichert, im Prinzip einen Zählerstand auf der Chipkarte und die Sicherheit beruht darauf, dass ich von außen diesen Zählerstand nicht manipulieren kann, sagen sie. In der Praxis ist es leider doch möglich das zu tun und das wissen sie auch, deshalb werden zu diesen Chipkarten sogenannte Schattenkonten geführt, das heißt zentral alle Buchungen, die ich auf der Chipkarte tätige, werden zentral noch mal zusammengeführt und es wird nachgerechnet ob auch ja irgendwie den Betrag, den ich vorher eingezahlt habe, dass er nicht überschritten wurde beim Abboten. Das heißt das System, die Geldkarte behauptet auch immer wieder von sich, sie wäre anonym und ist sie aber auch nicht. Also genauso bei Kreditkarten fällt bei der Geldkarte an einer zentralen Stelle eine Datenschleimspur an und die wiederum ist auf eine einzelne Person zurück zu dresen und das möchte man dann ja eigentlich doch nicht.
Also theoretisch, theoretisch, also man kann vielleicht sagen, laut Speck, laut Beschreibung steht bei dem Schattenkonto kein Name daneben, aber wenn ich da mit meiner EC-Karte einzahle oder dann zahle ich da ein und bei der EC-Karte steht mein Name dran, das heißt diese Zuordnung ist nicht schwierig.
Da der kurze Einwurf, also Geldkarte ist definitiv personen- und kontobezogen, es gibt die Ride-Karte, nach Einwürfen von Datenschützer.
Also es gibt auch, man kann Gerüchte zufolge bei den Sparkassen das kriegen, ich persönlich hab's noch nicht versucht. Das ist eine Geldkarte ohne EC-Funktion auf der gleichen Karte und wo auch der Kundenname nicht der Bank bekannt ist.
Das heißt, ich kederhin kaufe wie eine Telefonkarte so ein Ding.
Man kann die dann auch mit Bargeld aufladen, das sollte man auch tun, ansonsten hat man natürlich die gleichen Probleme wie vorher, aber auch die Geldkarte ist nicht sicher. Also gar nicht die Anonymität ist gar nicht das einzige Problem, sondern es geht auch darum, kann damit bedrohen werden und wenn bei der Geldkarte jemand betrügt, dann haftet der Händler, das heißt der nicht irgendeine Versicherung von den Herausbringern der Karten, wie das bei Kreditkarten ist, sondern der Händler haftet und das will man ja eigentlich nicht als Kunde. Deswegen benutzen wir hier eigentlich alle keine Geldkarten und würden euch das auch nicht empfehlen. Man kann übrigens sagen, als Kunde kann man sehen, ob ein Standard sicher ist oder nicht, je nachdem daran, ob der Betrag, den man damit höchstens ausgeben darf, limitiert ist oder nicht. Denn wenn die Banken wissen, dass ein System unsicher ist, dann limitieren sie den Betrag auf 400 Mark. Das gilt bankintern als Bagatellgrenze. Wenn es nämlich mehr Geld ist, was da verloren geht, dann würde es sich lohnen, hinterher zu forschen. Deswegen ist auf Geldkarten auch limitiert, dass da höchstens 400 Mark aufgeladen werden können. Also auch die Banken wissen, dass es unsicher ist und nicht anonym und deswegen fing er weg von Geldkarten.
An der Stelle muss man sich natürlich fragen, was ist denn die komplette Liste von Anforderungen an ein Zahlungsmittel, wie wir es gerne hätten im Internet. Und zwei Japaner, nämlich Okamoto und Ota, haben mal eine Liste aufgestellt. Sechs Features. Unabhängigkeit, also das Geld muss unabhängig von einem physikalischen Aufbewahrungsort sein. Es gibt da einige Konzepte, die beruhen darauf, dass man so eine sichere elektronische Geldbörse hat oder halt eine Chipkarte oder so was. Und das soll bei dem Protokoll nicht so sein. Das heißt, man muss in der Lage sein, das Geld beliebig zu kopieren, durch die Gegend zu schicken und so weiter und so fort. Man möchte ja auch vielleicht mal ein Backup von seinem Geld machen. Nachher geht diese Geldkarte kaputt und das Geld ist weg. Und das möchte man ja nicht.
Also das System sollte sich durch Eleganz im Design differenzieren und nicht durch irgendwelche komischen technischen Features auf irgendwelchen Smartcards.
Also die Sicherheit soll nicht daher kommen, dass irgendwie ein Mann mit Gold neben mir steht, wenn ich da Geld drauf tue, sondern die Sicherheit soll daher sein, dass man das Design offenlegen kann und trotzdem kein hartes Geld dran kommt.
Genau. Der zweite Punkt, der wichtig ist, ist Sicherheit. Das heißt, das Geld sollte nicht vervielfältigbar sein. Man sollte mit einer Münze nur genau einmal bezahlen können. Also das heißt schon, dass man in der Lage sein darf, das Geld zu kopieren. Mehrfach einmal soll es nur einmal ausgeben dürfen, um Betrug zu verhindern. Der dritte Punkt ist Schutz der Privatsphäre. Das heißt, man sollte als Inhaber von solchem Geld als derjenige, der mit diesem Geld bezahlt, anonym sein. Das ist zum Beispiel bei Bargeld ja gegeben. In Münzen haben sowieso keine Seriennummer. Geldscheine haben eine Seriennummer, die wird aber nicht standardmäßig erfasst. Wenn ich bei all die an der Kasse zahle, schreiben die sich nicht die Seriennummer auf. Und wenn die aus dem Geldautomaten rauskommen, wird auch nicht diese Seriennummer meinem Konto zugeordnet. Hoffentlich wird sich das nicht ändern. Wenn sich das ändert, ist das natürlich ein Problem. Aber es ist unseres Erachtens wichtig, dass Geld anonym ist. Die nächste Anforderung, die interessant ist, ist Offline-Payment. Das heißt, dass ich mit elektronischem Geld auch dann bezahlen können soll, wenn der Händler nicht an das Netz der Bank angeschlossen ist, also keine Online-Verbindung hat. Gut, es wird zunehmend unwichtiger, weil Online-Verbindungen zunehmend verbreitet sind. Die Protokolle, um tatsächlich Offline-Payment machen zu können, sind auch relativ komplex, erfordern große Datenmengen und sind auch nicht wirklich praktikabel. Eine weitere interessante Anforderung ist Übertragbarkeit. Also bei Bargeld ist es so, dass ich einfach meinem Kumpel einen Zehner in die Hand drücken kann und sagen kann, geh mal Bier holen. Und zum Beispiel mit einer Kreditkarte oder einer Geldkarte würde das überhaupt gar nicht funktionieren. Mit einer Kreditkarte sowieso nicht. Und mit einer Geldkarte müsste ich das Geld erst einzahlen oder überweisen und der kann sich abholen und das erfordert alles viel Aufwand. Und der sechste Punkt ist Unterteilbarkeit. Das heißt, wenn ich einen digitalen Geldschein habe, der 10 Mark repräsentiert, dann möchte ich in der Lage sein, daraus zweimal 5 Mark zu machen. Und auch dafür gibt es Protokolle, auch die sind noch nicht sehr weit verbreitet. Und insgesamt orientieren sich diese Anforderungen an den Features, die normales Bargeld hat, wie wir es im täglichen Leben verwenden. Also vielleicht bis auf die Geschichte mit der Teilbarkeit. Man kann leider kein 10 Mark Schein durchschneiden, um 2, 50 zu kriegen. Das wäre aber verdammt praktisch, wenn es so wäre. Deshalb ist das in der Liste der Anforderungen für das ideale System mal mit aufgenommen worden.
Gab es doch in England vor zig Jahren irgendwie, dass du München durchbrechen konntest? So hieß denn die.
Ja, das Piratenfilm vor der Herbe.
Und vor allem in Monkey Island.
Genau, Monkey Island.
Also das mit der Tracebarkeit von Bargeld, da gibt es auch immer wieder lustige Anekdoten, wenn doch mal was getraced wird. Und so eine witzige Sache sind so Statistiken, wie viel Geldscheine mit Kokain in Berührung gekommen sind, weil das sich ganz gut hält. Und da gibt es Statistiken von über 80 Prozent der Geldscheine. Und da gibt es auch gerade ein witziges Verfahren in den USA, wo es um Wahlspenden ging, an denen viel Kokain dran war, was dann nicht zurückgegeben werden sollte, weil es hieß, das sind Drogengelder. Und da ist dann diese Statistik zitiert worden, dass es sich eben doch bei den meisten Geldscheinen finden lässt, dass da irgendwelche Drogenspuren dran sind. Aber es geht eben um die Seriennummern letztendlich. Und die werden nicht standardmäßig erhoben, obwohl man es ja auch nicht wirklich weiß. Aber letztendlich geht es ja auch nicht nur darum, Geld abzubilden, sondern es geht darum, das Zahlungssystem zu definieren, was wir gerne haben wollen. Und das sind so die Basisanforderungen. Und man muss auch mal sagen, da wird seit vielen Jahren dran geforscht. Es gab da auch wirklich viele gute Leute, die sich damit beschäftigt haben. Und es ist auch nicht einfach, das umzusetzen. Und kann man sich ja schon so ein bisschen vorstellen als Zuhörer jetzt, der von Mathematik vielleicht nicht so viel Ahnung hat, aber der sich doch vorstellen kann, dass wenn ich Daten kopieren kann, dass es dann doch bestimmt nicht so einfach ist, festzustellen, wer jetzt zuerst zahlt, wenn ich nicht online sein soll bei der Bank. Und tatsächlich das Verfahren, um das es heute hier hauptsächlich gehen soll, eCash erfordert in der jetzigen Stufe der Implementation, dass der Händler direkt zur Bank läuft mit dem Geld. Obwohl es auch da Ergänzungen gibt zum Protokoll, die dafür führen sollen, dass der Händler nicht online sein muss. Aber man kann in Berlin schon ganz gut sehen hier. Da gibt es Berlincom, das ist eine lokale Telefongesellschaft der Wasserwerke. Da sind Ortsgespräche innerhalb Berlins schon jetzt kostenlos. Das heißt, da wäre es möglich, als Händler einfach die ganze Zeit mit der Bank verbunden zu sein, ohne dass da Kosten entstehen. Und wir denken, dass es in Zukunft öfter so sein wird. Das ist auch nicht nur in Berlin, gibt es solche Angebote, das gibt es öfter. Also die Zukunft geht deutlich daran hin, dass man ortsnahe Verbindungen für kostenlos oder für sehr geringe Kosten wird halten können, wenn die Bandbreite nicht so hoch ist. Und für Geld verifizieren braucht man nicht viel Bandbreite.
Okay, womit wir endlich schon beim Thema dieser Sendung werden? Also es gibt ja einen aktuellen Anlass für diese Sendung heute. Und das ist, dass die Deutsche Bank ihren E-Cash-Feldversuch in einen E-Cash-Produktionsbetrieb umgewandelt hat. E-Cash ist ein Internetzahlungsmittel, das interessanterweise nicht so sehr viele Leute kennen, obwohl es deutlich älter ist als andere Zahlungsverfahren. Also bereits 1995 gab es da die ersten Feldversuche mit. Und E-Cash ist halt das erste Protokoll, was die Anforderungen Anonymität erfüllt, was auch die Anforderungen Sicherheit hinreichend erfüllt. Deswegen wollen wir uns heute mal damit beschäftigen, was kann E-Cash? Was kann E-Cash in der Konfiguration, wie es bei der Deutschen Bank verwendet wird? Was hat das für Auswirkungen und so weiter und so fort?
Ich sag nochmal, wie die Sendung heißt und mach ne kleine Musik, oder?
Nachrichten mehr und immer um halb.
Falscher Sender. Chaosradio 48 und Andreas wollte E-Cash erläutern, wo ich eben große Augen gekriegt hab.
Man kann ja mal kurz so zwei grundsätzliche Arten, wie man Werte austauschen kann oder wie man sich gegenseitig versichern kann, dass man irgendwann später Werte austauschen wird, vorstellen. Das eine ist transaktionsbasiert, das heißt ich stell mich hin und sage jemandem, der etwas von mir haben möchte, ich gebe dir später das Geld und ich bürge dafür mit meinem guten Namen, wie diese Kartengesellschaften auch immer werben. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass da mein Name auch drunter steht, weil sonst klappt dieses Versprechen halt nicht. Das läuft im Internet halt meist, oder in einigen Verfahren über verschlüsselte Signaturen. Das heißt ich bestätige also letztes Thema, dass ich das wirklich war, mit einer Signatur unter dem Ding. Und dann wird das später von meinem Konto abgebucht, per Lastschrift erledigt oder sonst wie gemacht. Ein tokenbasiertes Verfahren, also ein System, wo ich etwas habe, wie einen Geldschein, das wäre zum Bleistift E-Cash, da habe ich halt den Geldschein vor mir. Das ist eine Datei, die Münze und dieser Münze kann ich halt in eine E-Mail stecken und die an jemanden schicken. Ich kann sie übers Internet, übers Web übertragen, ich kann sie automatisiert rüber schicken. Aber sobald jemand die Münze bei sich hat, hat er das Geld. Das heißt es findet danach keine weitere Wertübermittlung mehr statt, dass er jetzt nur das Versprechen hat, dass ich ihm später was zahle, sondern in dem Augenblick, wo die Münze bei ihm angekommen ist, geht er mit dieser Münze zur Bank, sagt hier so, guck mal meine Münzen, schüttet die bei denen auf den Schreibtisch und die sagen, okay jetzt gehören dir irgendwie 100 Mark mehr.
Naja, das muss man ein bisschen differenziert sehen, weil letztendlich die Münzen sind auch nur ein Reprozentiv.
Das ist bei realen Sachen aber auch das gleiche Spielchen.
Also witzigerweise gibt es ja auch beim digitalen Geld die gleiche Unterscheidung, die es bei realem Geld gibt, mit Scheinen, die wertvoll sind und wo Signaturen und wo Nummern draufstehen und bei Münzen, die für ganz winzige Sachen sind, es gibt so ein Micro-Payment-System, nennt man das, für sehr kleine Zahlungen, am besten auch so Bruchteile von Fändigen, wo man halt einen Klick auf eine Webseite bezahlt, am besten. Das sind so Systeme, wo die Transaktionen nicht so aufwendig sind und wo sie auch mit billigerer Hardware sind.
Aber darüber wollen wir nicht reden.
Nein, aber das soll ich mal kurz erwähnen. Also das wird tatsächlich viel abgebildet von denen, dass man so...
E-Cash ist im Prinzip eine Äquivalenz zum Geldschein und hat auch ungefähr so die Funktionalität von einem Geldschein. Auf dem Geldschein steht ja auch eine Seriennummer drauf. Und was im Wesentlichen passiert ist, wenn ich mit meiner E-Cash-Geldschein zu der Bank komme, ist, dass die nachgucken, ob diese Seriennummer schon einmal eingelöst wurde oder nicht. Und wenn sie schon mal eingelöst wurde, dann nehmen sie das einfach nicht an. Ansonsten nehmen sie dieses Geld an. Also ich kann auch den Geldschein nehmen, auf einen Fotokopierer legen und mit der Fotokopie zur Bank gehen. Wenn ich den echten Geldschein verbrenne und nicht zur Bank bringe, bekomme ich das Geld auch mit der Fotokopie. Und soweit so gut. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, woran erkennen sie, dass das Geld echt ist? Das erkennen sie daran, dass da eine Unterschrift drauf ist, wenn man mal einen Geldschein nimmt. Jeder hat ja sicherlich einen Geldschein in der Tasche und sollte vielleicht jetzt mal so einen Geldschein rausholen, die sich in aller Ruhe angucken.
Gerade um gerade spielen?
Nee, da nehme ich aber nicht den Schein. Also da ist einmal jede Menge Sicherheitsfeatures drauf. Die fallen im Internet weg, weil die kann man per Fotokopierer kopieren und das macht trotzdem nichts.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Da gibt es dann rechts unten die Serennummer und links gibt es die Unterschrift des Präsidenten der Bundesbank. Das ist mehr oder weniger das Entscheidende an dem ganzen Geldschein. Die ist das zwar auch nur drauf gedruckt, aber die macht den Geldschein als gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel. Und bei eCash ist die Unterschrift natürlich digital. Man kennt das vom PGP her. Da ist eine Signatur der Bank drunter. Das heißt, wenn ich den Geldschein zur Bank bringe, überprüfen die erst mal ihre digitale Unterschrift. Und dann ist der Geldschein echt. Dann gucken sie nach, ist die Seriennummer schon in der Datenbank? Und dann wissen sie, ob der Geldschein schon mal eingelöst wurde oder nicht. Und damit ist im Prinzip das Bezahlen schon fast erledigt. Jetzt hat die Geschichte noch einen Haken, und zwar das mit der Anonymität. So ein Geldschein hat ja eine Seriennummer. Und irgendwann hat die Bank ja mal diesen Geldschein unterschrieben. Man müsste nun meinen, jetzt kennt sie die Seriennummer. Und mathematisch steckt da, was jetzt gemacht wird, ist ein sogenanntes Blinding. Mathematisch betrachtet ist das, dass bei RSA das Unterschreiben und das Verschlüsseln kommutativ ist. Das heißt, man kann das vertauschen. Man kann sich das anschaulich so vorstellen, dass ich als Kunde einen Geldschein vorbereite. Das heißt, ich nehme mir ein weißes Blatt Papier, schreibe da rechts oben 100 Mark drauf, schreibe rechts unten eine Seriennummer hin. Dann tue ich das mit einem Stückchen Kohlepapier in Umschlag und bringe das zur Bank. Die Bank unterschreibt das von außen, sieht die Seriennummer nicht, gibt mir den Umschlag wieder. Wenn ich zu Hause bin, mache ich den auf, hab einen unterschriebenen Geldschein.
Und jetzt stellt sich noch die Frage, wie die Bank denn wissen kann, wenn sie nicht drauf guckt, dass das wirklich ein 100 Mark Schein war und nicht ein 1000 Mark Schein. Und das löst man relativ geschickt, indem man als Kunde der Bank nicht einen Briefumschlag gibt, sondern 1000 Briefumschläge. Und die Bank macht alle bis auf einen auf und guckt, also die Bank sucht aus, welche sie aufmacht, macht alle bis auf einen auf und guckt, ob jeweils das drin ist, was ich gesagt hab, was drin ist, nämlich einen 100 Mark Schein und glaubt mir dann, dass im letzten auch ein 100 Mark Schein ist. Und das 1000 ist jetzt willkürlich gewählt, da kann man noch eine Million nehmen. Der Punkt ist halt, je mehr ungeöffnete Briefumschläge ich der Bank gebe, desto geringer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Bank genau den einen, in dem ein größerer Schein drin ist, aufmacht. Das heißt, an der Stelle vielleicht ganz wichtig und wo viele Leute auch Probleme mit haben, ist, dass es wahrscheinlichheitsbasiert ist. Also es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass jemand die Bank bescheuert, indem er halt einen Riesenschlag macht.
Es ist extrem unwahrscheinlich. Es ist genauso unwahrscheinlich, wie das plötzlich durch kosmische Strahlung beim Abwuchen des Betrages von quantum in null dazu kommt.
Ich kann vielleicht mal sagen, was der Erfinder von den Verfahren sagte, als ihn mal jemand danach gefragt hat. Der hat einen Stift hochgehalten und hat gesagt, das wird auch nur durch Wahrscheinlichkeit zusammengehalten. Und das war nicht doch interessant als Realitätsabgleich.
Okay.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, wie bleibe ich anonym als Inhaber des Geldes?
Der Punkt ist halt, dass du der Bank gegenüber nicht auftrittst, sondern es ist ja elektronisch, das heißt über ein Kabel. Am Ende an einem Kabel kann jeder sitzen. Es kann ein Internetcafé sein, irgendwie völlig anonym. Das heißt, du gehst über Kabel zur Bank und machst das mit den Briefumschlägen und kriegst dann einen unterschriebenen Briefumschlag zurück, machst den Umschlag auf, nimmst das Kohlepapier raus und hast jetzt einen unterschriebenen Geldschrein, dessen Seriennummer die Bank nicht gesehen hat. Alles, was die Bank gesehen hat, ist die anderen Briefumschläge und deine IP-Nummer. Und das lässt sich sogar noch auf technischen Wegen verschleiern.
Moment, beim Unterschreiben des Geldes muss die Bank natürlich wissen, wer ich bin, weil die müssen das von meinem Konto abbuchen. Aber dadurch, dass sie die Seriennummer nicht zuordnen, können sie zwischen dem Abheben des Geldes und dem Ausgeben des Geldes keine Zuordnung herstellen. Also es ist so, als wenn im Geldautomaten eine Kamera eingebaut wäre, die aufschreibt, welche Seriennummern von Geldscheinen ich bekomme. Und wenn ich die dann im Laden ausgebe, die überprüfen das nicht, dann können sie das ja auch nicht feststellen. Funktioniert technisch anders bei E-Cash, nämlich genau andersrum, dass die Bank die Seriennummer nicht sieht. Aber der Händler.
Aber man kann ja vielleicht noch weitergehen. Wer jetzt aufgepasst hat, dem ist aufgefallen, dass der Händler ein Problem hat an der Stelle. Denn wenn ich da mit dem gleichen Geldschein zweimal oder zweimal bezahle, beim gleichen Händler vielleicht eine halbe Stunde Pause dazwischen und der Händler geht nicht gleich zur Bank damit und guckt, ob der Geldschein gültig war, dann hat er von mir weniger Geld bekommen, als er glaubt. Deswegen ist eCash in der Variante, die jetzt eingesetzt ist, ein Onlineverfahren. Das heißt, dass der Händler sofort zur Bank läuft und mir die 100 Mark den Gegenwert erst gibt, wenn die Bank Ja gesagt hat. Und das heißt, dass der Händler nicht Steuern hinterziehen kann. Der Händler kann nicht Bargeld von mir nehmen und damit in die Schweiz laufen in einem Koffer, sondern er muss sofort zur Bank laufen. Und das wird von manchen Leuten, die das erst mal hören, so ausgelegt wie, na ist doch gar nicht anonym, weil der Händler wird ja der Bank gegenüber auf. Aber das ist auch gar nicht die Anonymität, die man verhindern will.
Er tritt ja ohnehin auf.
Der Händler muss auf jeden Fall auftreten, weil wenn er seine Kohle mitnimmt, genau. Also der Händler tritt der Bank gegenüber sofort auf. Aber die Bank und der Händler, also der Händler weiß, wenn ich da kaufe, natürlich wer ich bin. Aber die Bank weiß es nicht, außer der Händler sagt sie. Das heißt grundsätzlich, der Händler hat kein Interesse daran, der Bank zu sagen, wer ich bin.
Sonst gehst du nicht mehr einkaufen.
Also auch der Händler braucht es nicht zu wissen, weil er weiß es nicht dann, wenn ich mich direkt über das Internet halte, wenn ich es mir schicken lasse, mit ihm verbinde oder halt die Adresse mit angebe für schicken.
Genau, für MP3 doch lohnt sich das nicht, aber wenn ich mir natürlich ein Päckchen schicke, dann ist da meine Adresse drauf. Aber letztendlich der Punkt ist eben, dass die Bank nicht weiß, wer er gekauft hat. Und das heißt, dass die Bank nicht zu onnen kann, der guckt viel Porno. Also die Bank kann sehen, Porno macht viel Umsatz, aber die Bank kann nicht sehen, was ich alles gekauft habe. Und es gibt auch keine andere Instanz, außer dem Händler, der koordinieren könnte, wenn er genau aufpasst, wer sich da was zuschicken lässt. Wie viele Leute, wie viel kaufen. Aber es sind keine weitergehenden Aussagen möglich, wie dass ich irgendwie den Grünen gerne Parteispenden mache. Sowas lässt sich dann halt nicht feststellen.
Ja, aber das ist doch auch wunderbar. Also ich meine, da regelt sich das sicher von selbst. Weil der Händler, also wenn der Händler anschenkt, das zu missbrauchen, gehst du nicht mehr da einkaufen. Das ist nicht sein Interesse.
Also, es kommt auf an, was man dir so bietet, ja.
Gut, also letztendlich natürlich kann da immer irgendwie ein Kartell sich von kriminellen Elementen bilden, die versuchen, mir irgendwie die Warnnur gegen Fingerabdruck zu geben und dann die Fingerabdrücke auswerten. Na klar, aber letztendlich, da kaufe ich dann nicht mehr. Also wenn so was an die Öffentlichkeit kommt, kauft man dann nicht mehr. Das kann man vielleicht jetzt an DoubleClick ganz gut sehen, wie sowas zurückschlagen kann. Die haben ja auch angefangen, Profile zu bilden und das stört erstmal keinen die Möglichkeit, dass es vielleicht ginge. Aber wenn es kommt, dann gibt es da Massivärger, die werden gerade übelst verklagt in den Staaten.
Also dazu muss man sagen, DoubleClick irgendwie muss man eigentlich dankbar sein. Also den Jungs wollte man irgendwie Blumen schicken, nicht ihren Anwalt finanzieren, das auf keinen, aber auf jeden Fall richtig, richtig dankbar sein, weil nach dem DoubleClick diesen riesen Skandal zum Thema verursacht hat, ist das Thema Anonymität im Internet und die Benutzerprofile, die halt von solchen Anbietern hergestellt werden, ganz krass Thema da drüben. Und es wird tatsächlich auch bei Zahlungssystemen verstärkt auf Anonymität, auf Nicht-Zurückverfolgbarkeit, auf Nicht-Profilerstellbarkeit geachtet. Also da ist plötzlich Interesse dran.
Ja und das ist überhaupt erstmal ein Thema. Wann hast du sonst noch darüber gelesen oder so?
Ja, es gab da so einen zweiten Vorfall vor drei Monaten, der das Ganze auch wirklich zum Thema gemacht hat. Das war ein netter junger Mann, irgendwo aus Russland wurde berichtet. Auch war ja nichts genau, das weiß man nicht.
Vor drei Tagen war auch noch so ein Ding, was schön Presse gemacht hat, nämlich das von Bill Gates die Kreditkarten, wo mal irgendwo gepostet werden soll. Das freut uns natürlich gewaltig, weil da kann man viel mit einkaufen gehen. Aber die Awareness ist einfach vorher nicht da gewesen. Die Leute haben es nicht so als Gefahr oder auch nicht als was Schlechtes gesehen, dass ihre Daten da verkauft werden. Und natürlich ärgert man sich, wenn die GEZ einen Brief schreibt, obwohl man ihr gar nicht mitgeteilt hat, dass man eine Glotze hat. Und wenn irgendwie Werbebotschaften kommen, die irgendwie Sachen wissen, die sie nicht wissen sollten, das ärgert einen auch ein bisschen.
Die Z-Professionell schickt mir dauernd irgendwie was.
Also sowas ist ein bisschen ärgerlich, wenn persönliche Daten in falsche Hände kommen, aber es ist nicht wirklich lebensbedrohlich. Und die meisten haben es auch nicht als Problem gesehen. Und die Sachen in letzter Zeit haben eben dafür gesorgt, dass es so langsam anfängt aufzufallen.
Also was irgendwo ein Argument noch für das Thema ist, weil man sich ja sonst fragt irgendwie, warum bezahlt man denn nicht mit seinem guten Namen? Ich weiß nicht, ich hab mir einen Vice President von Cybercash mal gefragt, was wir Deutschen denn alle so mit dem anderen Thema Anonymität hätten. Das würde sie so gar nicht verstehen. In Amiland würden halt alle mit Kreditkarte zahlen und alles wäre gut. Und auf den Hinweis, dass wir hier in diesem Ländle in den letzten 100 Jahren oder im letzten Jahrhundert doch öfter mal so ein paar Probleme mit unseren Regierungen gehabt hätten, also nicht so wirklich Glück gehabt, da hat sie dann irgendwann verstanden, also.
Ja, ich werde hier gerade im Chat gefragt, ob wir zu viel Porto gucken. Das ist natürlich nicht die einzige Begründung dafür, warum wir gerne Anonymität haben wollen.
Aber eine.
Ja, na gut.
Eine die einleuchtet. Das ist glaube ich die meisten heute nachvollziehbar.
Genau, ist eine breite Sorgsamheit.
Es ist natürlich auch so, dass letzten Endes es keine angeht, wenn ich mir irgendwie Zahnpasta im Internet kaufe, weil es ist ja irgendwann mal illegal, mir wird ein Strick draus gedreht, keine Ahnung, das möchte ich einfach nicht. Ich möchte von vorne rein, dass keiner irgendwas über mich weiß.
Ja oder ausschließen, dass irgendwer mal weiß, was für Bücher du in den letzten fünf Jahren beispielsweise gelesen oder zumindest gekauft hast. Genau, genau.
Aber es gibt auch noch andere Sachen so politisch motiviert. Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass die Regierung korrupt ist, und das muss ja gar nicht hier sein, das kann auch in anderen Ländern sein, dann ist es schon wichtig, dass auch potenziell der Kunde dem Händler gegenüber anonym bleiben kann, weil ansonsten könnte die Regierung zu Händlern gehen und sagen, der ist auf unserer Abschlussliste, verkauft dem nichts mehr. Es gibt öfter in irgendwelchen kriminellen Regimes, gab es, dass die Widerstandsbewegungen irgendwelche intellektuellen waren und wenn man den Buchläden sagt, den dürft ihr keine Bücher mehr verkaufen, das wäre ein echtes Problem für die. Und deswegen ist Anonymität wichtig. Also man kann da beliebig tolle Fälle kommen. Letztendlich ist es so, dass es keinem was angeht und dass man es eigentlich auch nicht sollte rechtfertigen müssen. Das ist schon eine Sache, an der wir auch arbeiten, dass der Öffentlichkeit mal ein bisschen klar zu machen, dass Anonymität ein Recht ist, was natürlich manche Leute willentlich aufgeben können für sich, aber das macht es nicht für andere.
Das Problem ist, sie tun das aus Unwissenheit. Das sind ja eigentlich in der Regel erst mal junge Leute, die noch gar nicht mit Werbung zugeschissen werden, die dann schon mal irgendwo bei einem Preisausschreiben mitmachen oder so.
Werbung ist nur eine Sache.
Na gut, aber das ist so das offensichtlichste Woran man es merkt.
Aber Werbung ist so, ich finde Werbung immer ein schlechtes Argument, weil Werbung nicht wirklich ein Problem ist. Es kostet mich ja nichts außer ein bisschen Zeit. Aber was mich echt ärgert ist, wenn irgendwelche Leute mir zielgerichtete Angebote machen.
Als Profi blablabla.
Genau, ich werde zum Beispiel von irgendeinem EDV Verlag immer angeschrieben, der mir erklären will, seien Sie der erste, der das Internet versteht. So eine Sache, das stört mich enorm. Also das ist natürlich auch Werbung, aber letztendlich, das ist nur unsere Gesellschaft hat uns halt von vielen Sachen weit genug abstrahiert, dass uns einfach viele Sachen nicht mehr betreffen, die da sein könnten, aber man muss sich nur mal 50 Jahre zurückdenken, wenn irgendwie ein anderes Regime hier an der Macht ist oder...
Manche Leute müssen ja nur 10 Jahre zurückdenken.
Ja, manche Leute müssen nur 10 Jahre zurückdenken, genau. Also letztendlich ist es nicht gut, dass der Staat oder irgendeine andere Instanz Daten über die Leute sammelt, die er nicht haben muss. Das ist einfach eine Sache, die muss man einfach als Grundrecht der Leute akzeptieren. Jeder hat ein Recht darauf, dass seine Daten nach seinem Wissen und Willen nur gespeichert werden.
Ja, ich würde vorschlagen, dass wir nach der nächsten Musik mal ein paar Hörer reinnehmen, und zwar würde uns interessieren, ob ihr schon mal über das Internet etwas eingekauft habt und jeder bezahlt habt, ob ihr da irgendwie ein schlechtes Gefühl dabei hattet, ob ihr vielleicht eingekauft hättet, wenn ihr gewusst hättet, dass es anonym ist, dass es sicher ist, dass da nichts passieren kann und wie ihr dann diese E-Cash Geschichte seht.
Die Fritz Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam 7097 110.
Das ist doch Unterhaltung.
Unterhaltung ist das, ja. Abrupp Unterhaltung, lasst uns nochmal hier mit jemandem unterhalten.
Oh ja, gute Idee.
Guten Abend, wer bist denn du?
Ich bin der Bademeister.
Ihr habt einen Bademeister? Was scheppert denn da bei euch Jungs?
Ja, ich hab hier ein Keyboard, was ihr durch die Gegend klüft.
Achso, ja gut, schmeiß weg.
Warum habt ihr heute keine Aufnahmeleiter?
Ja, wir hören uns die Antwort nicht in Frage. Wollen lieber selber entscheiden, wer doof ist und wer nicht.
Genau. Ja, Firewall muss nicht.
Niemand darf sich eine Firewall zu errichten. Bademeister, was ist denn, Mo?
Ja, also ich hab schon mal, also wir haben so in der Klasse, so auf Cake, immer über das Internet Sachen für Angebestellte. Bei Fritz ist das Ding nicht leicht, also Fritz kam da. Da kannst du bestellen ohne Ende. Das geht überhaupt keiner mit, weil du brauchst bloß deine E-Mail bestätigen. Dann wird das geliefert.
Du hast ja nur einen riesen Hack, ne? Was?
Mich?
Sachen zu bestellen?
Ja, dachte ich.
Boah, ist das ein Hack, ey.
Naja, vor allem auf andere Leute Namen ist schon noch viel.
Der nächste bitte. Der nächste bitte, hallo ich hin.
Ich hatte mal eine Frage. Und zwar, ihr habt vor 10, 15 Minuten so einen Titel gespielt, ja.
Ob ihr denn mal mal ein Label, wo ich jetzt einen kann, sagen?
Das ist ein Album von Afex Twin, was ich hier habe. Afex Twin und das heißt Selected Ambient Works 85-92. Ist also ein Sampler. Jetzt frag mich nicht, was das war. Ich hab die einfach durchlaufen lassen. Danke euch. Versuchen wir mal nicht nochmal sechs. Hallo, wer bist denn du? Hallo Katja, willst du wissen, wie irgendeine Platte hieß, warum wir keinen Aufnahmeleiter haben? Aber was du möchtest, ist dein Radio leise machen bitte, aber ganz schnell. Okay, jetzt.
Ja, also ich wollte eigentlich mehr auf eure Frage eingehen.
Das finden wir gut.
Und zwar also ich kaufe mir meine Flugtickets übers Internet und bezahle aber nur per Rechnung. Also ich finde das andere irgendwie hab ich da nicht mehr. Bisschen Angst. Wenn ich jetzt ja meine Kreditkartnummer hingeben würde oder sowas.
Du hast das Radio immer noch an gerechtfertigt.
Es gibt ja auch bei Kreditkarten immer wieder Fälle, wo die Übertragung ja toll verschlüsselt ist mit HTTPS und so weiter und so fort. Und dann aber leider der Einrichter der Webseite zu blöd ist und dann auf irgendeiner Webseite die kompletten Kunden Daten, inklusive Kreditkarte abrufbar sind.
Ja eben deswegen. Also ich vertraue denen einfach nicht.
Und würdest du, wenn es ein anonymes und sicheres Zahlungsmittel gibt, das auch direkt bezahlen wollen?
Wenn mir jemand garantieren könnte, dass es sicher ist, dann schon, ja.
Das ist übrigens gutes Verfahren, um Banken auszuwählen. Wenn deine Bank dir nämlich sagt, dass du schuld bist, wenn irgendein Problem ist mit deiner Online-Banking-Sachen, wenn du da irgendwie irgendeiner dir Geld abhebt und die Bank sagt, na ist halt dein Problem, dann ist das eine schlechte Bank.
Dann bleibt normalerweise keine gute Bank übrig.
Ja, es gibt die Haspa, macht das wohl so. Hab ich mir sagen lassen. Die Haspa soll irgendwie die einzige Bank sein, die...
Es gibt diverse Kriterien, an denen man das messen kann. Und zwar ist es generell bei diesen ganzen Sicherheitsprodukten so, dass die Sicherheit im Wesentlichen davon abhängig ist, dass möglichst viele Leute sich das angeguckt haben und gesagt haben, dass das System sicher ist. Und die meisten veröffentlichen halt nicht, wie es funktioniert und halten das geheim. Und wenn es dann doch rauskommt, wird es schnell geknackt. Also das ist auch ein Gradmesser dafür, für die Sicherheit, wenn das Verfahren offengelegt ist, wenn das alles wohl dokumentiert ist, dann kann man eher dazu neigen, dem zu vertrauen.
Also man kann vielleicht mal als Hausnummer sagen, es gibt auf der Welt...
Machst du bitte mal dein Radio aus?
Also es gibt auf der Welt ungefähr drei Leute, die man glaubt, wenn sie sagen, wir haben ein neues Verfahren und das ist sicher. Es gibt einfach mehr Leute, gibt es nicht. Das heißt, wenn deine Hausbank dir erzählt, ja das ist jetzt sicher, weil das hat ein Spezialist gemacht, dann glaubt ihr nicht.
Also von Online-Banking halt sowieso nicht viel.
Na ja, also Online-Banking ist grundsätzlich nicht schlecht, aber die Frage ist einfach, ob die Bank sagt, alles deine Schuld oder nicht. Und wenn die Bank im eigenen Verfahren eh nicht traut und sagt, naja, dann hauen wir lieber den Kunden aufs Konto, dann ist das schon ein schlechtes Zeichen eigentlich.
Meine Bank ist doch richtig cool. Also es ist so eine ganz kleine Sparkassen-Filiale in der Nähe von Köln. Ich sag gar nicht mehr. Die sagen, wissen Sie, Herr Klein, können Sie ja gerne machen, aber schicken Sie uns lieber eine Überweisung per Post.
Das find ich total grandios.
Ja echt, darum hab ich auch immer noch mein Konto bei denen, obwohl ich 600 Kilometer weit weg wohne, weil ich das irgendwie sehr gut finde. Bitte schön. Das war's von dir aus, wir nehmen mal den nächsten dran, ja? Wer haben wir denn da jetzt?
Ich hatte vorhin schon mal jemand bei euch an der Strippe, den hab ich ein paar Fragen gestellt, aber der meinte, ich sollte einfach mal die Hotline anrufen.
Vielleicht mal eine Frage, wo er los ist.
Im Prinzip schon. Also wenn man die Hotline anruft, den wir dran. Das ist unser Los.
Wie, das heißt jetzt rufen hier die Leute an, die gerade bei Media Markten Rechner gekauft haben?
Höhö, könnt ja mal versuchen. Wenn ihr gerade bei Media Markten Rechner gekauft habt...
Wie war die Nummer der Konkurrenz? Äh, ne.
Ja, dann sag doch mal deine Probleme.
Ja, und zwar hab ich mir jetzt erstmal Rechner zugelegt. Dank Bellycom, free Internet, macht das langsam auch ein bisschen Spaß. Und ist nicht mehr so teuer. Und hab mir jetzt auch alles zukommen lassen, von der Dresdner Bank und der Deutschen Bank. Und da bin ich auch so mit diesem E-Cash drüber bekommen. Deswegen fand ich das ziemlich gut, dass ihr das gerade angesprochen habt. Und wenn man jetzt Überweisung tätigt, hatten wir auch gerade eben das Thema. Da muss man so TIN und PAN angegeben. Und da gibt es jetzt noch ein zweites Verfahren. Kennt ihr euch damit aus?
Na, es gibt da ganz viele Verfahren, kannst du dir beliebig viele Verfahren ausdenken. Aber grundsätzlich ist es so, wenn du PIN und TAN hast, dann musst du dich der Bank gegenüber nicht zweifelsfrei authentisiert haben. Andererseits anderweitig. Also man kann auch mit Verschlüsselungen das so machen, dass der User sich in seinem Browser einen Key generiert, das ist dann SSL3 oder TLS, und dann kann die Bank anhand der Browserverschlüsselung feststellen, ob du du bist. Aber das heißt eben auch, dass du nicht aus dem Internetcafé mal kurz eine Überweisung machen kannst. Wenn du aber PIN und TAN hast, dann geht das doch. Deswegen finde ich das persönlich besser mit PIN und TAN.
Ja und die ganzen Verfahren, die halt darauf basieren, dass du dich mit deinem Browser oder mit irgendetwas, was auf deinem Rechner lagert, der Bank gegenüber ausweist, basieren halt auch auf der Sicherheit deines eigenen Rechners. Und wenn du da halt Bank-Oreficien oder sowas drauf hat, dann kann halt jemand die Zeit, wo du gerade mal irgendwie pinkeln bist, irgendwie da nutzen, um irgendwie beliebig viele Überweisungen loszutreten.
Vor allem darf man das eh nicht unter Windows machen, weil wenn immer deine Platte von Windows quasi nicht anformatiert wurde, ist halt auch dein Key weg. Und dann hast du ein Problem, um mit der Bank zu reden. Also so ein Verfahren finden wir eigentlich nicht so toll. Deswegen PIN und TAN sind okay. Und PIN und TAN haben natürlich auch Probleme. Also wenn irgendwie ihr eine Software einsetzt, die euch bittet PIN und TAN einzugeben, damit sie dann immer schön Überweisung machen kann. Das macht nicht, ja immer schön manuell alles machen, weil da gab es auch schon einen wunderbaren Fall, wo wir nicht ganz unbeteiligt waren zu Demonstrationszwecken. Also PIN und TAN sind nicht schlecht, sondern im Gegenteil, das ist gut.
Und zwar wenn man bei Free Internet sich für Bellicom anmeldet, kommt man netterweise, weil die nach ein bisschen Geld von Bellicom bekommen, so ein Chipkartenlesegerät. Und die Dresdabank gibt auch so eine Chipkarte aus.
Also Bellicom ist daran unbeteiligt, ne? Ja. Das nennt sich HWCI, was du da gerade beschreibst.
Ja, das ist einfach nur, ich denke mal, Free Internet bekommt dann Provision darauf, dass sie dann sozusagen einen anmelden bei Bellicom. Und als Dankeschön bekommt man von denen so ein Chipkartenlesegerät.
In welches Interesse soll denn Bellicom daran haben?
Für Bellicom ist es Kundenwerbung. Für die Dresdner Bank ist es eine gute Gelegenheit, den Leuten HWCI-Chipkartenleser aufzudrücken.
Nee, das macht Internet free. Aber in Dresdner Bank gibt es eine Chipkarte raus, mit der man sich dann, wenn man auf Kontoüberweisungen tätigen will oder so auszeichnet.
Ja, das ist genau HWCI, was er eben angesprochen hat. Und das, was du da gerade gekriegt hast, ist halt ein Bandingangebot, wo halt einer von beiden dem anderen Anbieter, also jetzt die Bank, dem Online Provider oder andersrum, halt Geld dafür gibt, dass sie dir gleich noch was mitverkaufen oder halt was mit schenken. Wie zum Beispiel diesen Kartenleser, was heute das eine des größeren Problems bei der Einführung von HWCI ist, dass halt kaum jemand so einen Kartenleser zu Hause hat und auch kaum jemand bereit ist, knapp 100 Mark für so einen Teil auszugeben, bloß damit er jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen Onlinebanking machen kann.
Ich hatte eigentlich gehofft oder gedacht, dass das sicherer ist mit dieser Karte, weil wenn man da immer sein Coup durch Internet jagt, ist es kein Problem, es irgendwie abzufangen, aber wenn man das mit so einer Karte macht, hab ich gehofft, dass es vielleicht sicherer ist.
Es ist nicht wirklich viel sicherer als Pin und Tan, es ist ein bisschen bequemer, weil man nicht ständig seine Tanz erneuern muss.
Eigentlich ist es gar nicht sicherer als Pin und Tan. Das ist nämlich eigentlich der Grund, das Problem ist immer wenn man was in der Hand hat, was man dann irgendwie halt, Anführungsstriche, sicher in der Jackentasche bei sich haben kann, hat man dann natürlich ein gewisses subjektives Sicherheitsgefühl, aber das ist eigentlich weitgehend illusorisch.
Das kommt von der PR-Abteilung.
Ganz grundsätzlich, ganz grundsätzlich.
Naja, aber ob ich jetzt irgendwie meine Chipkarte verliere oder den Stapel Tanz verliere, ist eigentlich auch kein Unterschied mehr.
Ja eben, ganz genau.
Also es ist eigentlich ganz genauso sicher, nur dass so eine Chipkarte natürlich viel schicker aussieht. Aber HWCI hat...
Sicher ist es, dass jemand diese Daten auf dem Weg zur Bank abfangen kann und sozusagen mit meinem Sport einkaufen kann.
Das ist im beiden Teil gleich. Das ist nicht davon abhängig, ob du jetzt eine Chipkarte oder eine TAN hast.
Also einfach nur einfach.
Genau, also letztendlich kannst du mal zu deiner beliebten Bankfigur gehen und einmal den Vordeiangang und einmal den Lieferanteneingang betrachten und wenn der Vordeiangang drei Kameras hat und der Lieferanteneingang gar keiner, dann weißt du, dass es so wie bei fast allen anderen Banken und so ist das eben in Sicherheit. Wenn das nach außen schön sicher aussieht, dann hat der Kunde ein gutes Gefühl und lässt sein Geld lieber bei der Bank und das ist der Hintergrund. Also HWCI ist nicht intrinsisch sicherer oder unsicherer als PIN und TAN. Aber komfortabler. Aber es ist halt komfortabler.
Sollte HWCI nicht auch für Überweisungen verwendet werden? Also für E-Commerce Transaktionen?
Nein, aber es gibt ja keinen, der das entgegennimmt.
Naja, noch nicht, aber da sind wir eigentlich schon wieder beim Thema.
Eigentlich waren wir E-Cash haben.
Genau, HWCI hat nämlich wieder genau das Problem. Also man kann damit ja nicht nur Online-Banking machen, sondern auch bezahlen. Das ist ja das Thema unserer Sendung. Online-Banking ist ja gar nicht unser Thema.
Lass uns doch mal zum Thema zurückkommen, nachdem wir vielleicht Nicole geholt haben und sie die Nachrichten gemacht hat.
Oh Scheiße, fünf Minuten drüber.
Nein, das ist nicht so schlimm. Das ist ja das Chaosradio. Aber ich dachte mir, bevor wir jetzt eine Viertelstunde drüber gehen, sage ich mal Bescheid.
Na dann sagen wir schon mal Tschüss und gehen gleich noch mal auf das Thema HWC.
Alles klar. Tschüsschen, danke für deinen Anruf. So, Nicole, du hast den Kopfhörer auf? Ach, das ist doch klasse. Dann mache ich jetzt mal wieder das Geräusch. 23 Uhr und sagt es keinem weiter und 36 Minuten.
Nazi-Überfall. Rechtsextreme haben in Brandenburgischen Wrieten eine Hetzjagd auf linksgerichtete Jugendliche verübt. Dabei wurde ein 14-jähriger lebensgefährlich verletzt. Den Überfall, der sich bereits am 10. März ereignete, deckte der Tagesspiegel auf. Die Polizei erklärte auf Anfrage, der wahre Sachverhalt habe sich erst später herausgestellt. Absicht. US-Präsident Clinton will eng mit dem russischen Staatschef Putin zusammenarbeiten. Dies läge im Interesse beider Staaten, sagte Clinton. Er hoffe auf Wirtschaftsreform und Kooperation bei der Rüstungskontrolle. Rückzug. Im Verkehrsverbund Berlin Brandenburg wird es zum 1. April keine Tariferhöhung geben. Der Aufsichtsrat wird am 12. April über Höhe und Zeitpunkt einer Tarifanpassung entscheiden. In den nächsten 14 Tagen soll auch ein Beschluss zu den Fahrkarten für den Berliner C-Bereich fallen. Abbau. Die Deutsche Bahn will auch bei den Ausbildungsplätzen sparen. Ein Sprecher kündigte an, dass in diesem Jahr etwa 1000 Lehrlinge weniger angenommen würden als 1999. Tarifverhandlung. Die Gespräche für die 3, 1 Millionen Beschäftigten des öffentlichen Dienstes sind am Abend ohne Annäherung auf den 14. April vertagt worden. Die Gewerkschaften fordern fünf Prozent mehr Lohn und eine Angleichung der Osttarife. Fußball. Das Testländerspiel Kroatien-Deutschland endete mit eins zu eins.
Wetter.
In der Nacht bis drei Grad, morgen gelegentlich Regen bis zehn Grad. A15 und A13 von der Grenzübergangsstelle Forst bis zum Kreuz Schönefeld fährt ein Schwerlasttransport mit Überbreite, der nicht überholt werden kann. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin, Biestorf in Richtung Mitte. An der Frankfurter Allee, Kreuz und Gürtelstraße, sind die Ampeln ausgefallen. Also, pass auf.
Ein kurzer Info mit der Liebereitsinn Nicole Markwald. Herzlichen Dank, 23 Uhr 38. Nee, hier muss ja noch das kommen. Ja. Wir haben die Musik angepasst, haben uns gerade... Wer ist denn hier am Telefon?
Ja hallo, hier ist der Andreas.
Ja Peace Andreas.
Ja hallöchen, ich hab ne Frage und vor allem vor einer halben Stunde so ein richtig genialer Track.
Vor einer viertel Stunde hat schon mal jemand angerufen. Der gesagt hat das von einer Viertelstunde.
Das war irgendetwas von Apex Twin, wo wir nicht wissen wie es heißt, weil wir nicht drauf geguckt haben, weil die CD einfach durchgelaufen ist.
Aber schade.
Ja ne jammer schade.
Ja richtig schade, weil der Titel ist richtig genial und ich wollte eigentlich nur den Mike jetzt gerade grüßen.
Ja dann hack noch ein bisschen, Tschüss. So und wer ist dran?
Meine Frage ist folgende. Ich glaube, dass es wichtig ist, dass die Leute, die das Internet am Ende auch benutzen, dass die jetzt schon irgendwie, also bei der Bildung des Systems des ganzen E-Commerce, dass die das schon irgendwie mitwirken.
Ja das wollen wir hier erreichen, indem wir erzählen, was das für Auswirkungen an Technologien hat, was da jetzt eingeführt wird auf der einen oder auf der anderen Seite.
Ja, also wenn du wirklich mitarbeiten willst, da draußen sind noch viele, viele Glasfaserkabel, die gelegt werden müssen, also mit einer Schaufel und irgendwie in einem kleinen Eimerchen kann man auf jeden Fall...
Nee, aber...
Nee, also zu dem Thema, zum Thema mitwirken, das könnte man auch kurz erwähnen, geh mal zu www.icann.org und schau dir das da an oder members.icann.org. Da findet gerade irgendwie so ein bisschen Demokratisierung in obersten Instanzen des Internets statt, also wer da sich mal engagieren möchte.
Ja ich glaube aber dafür ist das Know-how wichtig und das hab ich noch nicht. Aber ihr, also zumindest guckt mir so vor, als wenn ihr da ein bisschen mitwirken könntet.
Dann machen wir doch was.
Ja ich meine aber das Erzählen, das wird nicht viele Leute erreichen.
Dich zum Beispiel. Irgendwo muss man anfangen.
Ja sicher auf jeden Fall, das denk ich auch. Nun gibt es nicht eine Möglichkeit, dass noch mehr Leute, die auch später, also sagen wir in den 20 Jahren, oder dass die Kinder von irgendwelchen alten Leuten, die haben ja auch Interesse am Internet und dem was sich jetzt bildet, dass jetzt größere Schichten der Bevölkerung schon an der an der Entwicklung teilhaben können.
Na ja, solange Tennis Spieler das Internet verkaufen, wird da glaube ich teilweise ins Leere geredet werden und teilweise auch ins Leere gehofft werden oder nicht.
Also jeder der will kann sich da wunderbar einbringen und es gibt schon tagesfüllende Fernsehprogramme, die sich nur mit Internet beschäftigen.
Das ist natürlich ein gewaltiges Problem, dass irgendwie für 95% der Leute das Internet nur so eine Art Fernsehersatz ist und dass sich weniger Gedanken über die tatsächliche Gestaltung der Gesellschaft machen, der ja stattfindet. Also es ist ja so, dass das Internet nicht nur ein neues Medium ist, sondern dass es auch die Gesellschaft verändert und dass es einfach viel zu wenige Leute bewusst ist. Also wenn du eine Idee hast, wie man das besser machen könnte, dann lass sie uns wissen, wir probieren zu informieren und Leute auf Probleme hinzuweisen und Technologietransparenz zu machen, auch die Auswirkungen davon transparent zu machen.
Die Idee habe ich nicht.
Nein, aber dann kann ich vielleicht auch mal allgemein über diesen Kanal hier sagen, wenn ihr Ideen habt, dann müsst ihr jetzt hier nicht anrufen, weil wir haben hier eh nichts zu schreiben da. Sondern da schreibt eine Mail an den CCC und die E-Mail-Andressen findet ihr auf unserem Webserver www.ccc.de und da versuchen wir auch Sachen zu publizieren, von denen wir glauben, dass das deutsche Volk sie wissen muss. Und deswegen geht da alle hin und liest das. Und das ist unsere Methode, wie wir der Welt unsere Inhalte übertragen, wenn wir nicht gerade am Radio sind.
Ja, und habt ihr schon ein anderes Protokoll nebenher, neben den von der Industrie geschaffen für E-Commerce?
Naja, also dieses E-Cash-Protokoll ist gar nicht so schlecht. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen merkwürdig. Also ich hab mir das von einigen Leuten in letzter Zeit anhören müssen. Was du propagierst, ein Protokoll, das von der deutschen Bank in die Industrie gebracht wird. Und das klingt natürlich erstmal ein bisschen verdächtig. Aber es ist so, dass E-Cash momentan das geringste Übel ist. Es ist also von der Theorie her hervorragendes Protokoll, das eben gerade solche Geschichten wie Anonymität und Sicherheit und so weiter und so fort ermöglicht. Und jetzt wird es eigentlich langsam eine Zeit, dass wir uns mal die konkrete Umsetzung angucken. Nur zur deutschen Bank kann man stehen wie man möchte. Eigentlich wäre es besser, wenn...
Ich schmeiß gerade mal Andreas aus der Leitung.
Uns wäre es lieber, wenn die Bundesbank dir auch das Geld herausgibt, auch elektronisches Geld herausgibt und nicht, dass das eine auf eine Bank begrenzte gewährliche Währung wäre. Also so richtig zufrieden sind wir da auch nicht damit, dass es sich dabei nur um die Deutsche Bank handelt. Aber immerhin geht die einen Schritt nach vorne.
Ist der Unterschied, dass es die Deutsche Bank ist? Das ist doch die Bank aller Deutschen, habe ich immer gedacht.
Das ist das, was der Brite glaubt.
Da stand im Guardian, du hast völlig recht.
Es gibt also Unterschiede im Detail. Und das zweite ist natürlich, dass wir auch mit der praktischen Umsetzung so unsere Probleme haben. Also zum Beispiel gibt es den Source Code nicht für die Clients. Und eigentlich ist der Source Code wichtig dafür, dass man überprüfen kann, dass diese Software tatsächlich das tut, was man von ihr möchte, dass da nicht noch eine Hintertür eingebaut ist. Und es gibt aber Leute, die an sowas arbeiten. Es gibt also eine Implementation, die sich hingesetzt haben, die dieses Protokoll nochmal umgesetzt haben als Open Source Software. Und nur leider ist es relativ komplexer, tatsächlich eine Wirtschaft mit zu betreiben. Also im Prinzip kommt man nicht darum, sich eine Bank zu suchen, die einem dabei hilft, mit diesem Protokoll dann auch tatsächlich Transaktionen zu machen. Weil du musst ja dann letzten Endes dich hinstellen, garantieren, dass die Leute ihr Geld bekommen. Und dafür braucht man nur mal eine Bank.
Also man kann vielleicht auch mal zur Deutschen Bank sagen, Deutsche Bank ist einfach ein großer Konzern mit vielen Lägern von Schlipsen, die da irgendwie sitzen und irgendwelche Entscheidungen treffen. Und teilweise wird da eben mit Würfel entschieden. Und in diesem Fall kam eben zufällig mal ein gutes Protokoll vorbei und ist zufällig gewählt worden. Und ob da nur die Deutsche Bank hinter steht oder irgendwer sonst, ist uns eigentlich relativ wurscht. Das Einzige, was uns im Moment stört, ist, dass der Quellcode nicht offen liegt.
Na ja, ganz uninteressant.
Ja, es ist nicht uninteressant, aber es ist nicht wirklich kriegsentscheidend, ob jetzt die Deutsche Bank oder die Dresdner machen das.
Nee, aber das ist genau das Problem. Weil welche Bank da draußen das macht, also die Dresdner und die Deutsche haben halt zwei entgegengesetzte Varianten im Programm. Und da wird halt ein Verfahren, ein Protokoll, das irgendwie sehr nett sein könnte, wenn es zum Beispiel die Bundesbank machen würde, einfach als irgendwie, ok, es gibt jetzt die Scheine und dann gibt es auch diese kleinen Münzen und die sind im Prinzip das gleiche Wert. Aber so wird es halt zum Marketinginstrument, zur Kundengewinnung und zum Kontoverkaufen. Und da ist dann natürlich eine elektrische Währung schon wieder mehr Marketinginstrument und Verkaufsmittel als das, was es eigentlich sein kann, nämlich eine Möglichkeit, wie man sich, wenn man im Internet lebt und dort auch halt wie man so, wenn man lebt, irgendwie ab und zu mal Werte austauschen möchte, verständigen kann, im Sinne von mal 5 Mark von einem zum anderen drüber geben.
Wobei allerdings die Frage, welche Bank das jetzt ausgibt, geht also durchaus noch wesentlich weiter. Weil damit natürlich auch mit der Verbreitung, dieses Zahlungssystems auch überhaupt die Auswirkung auf die gesamte Wirtschaft und natürlich ganz andere Dimensionen. Also grundsätzlich hat man ja bei jedem Zahlungsmittel, ganz egal, ob das jetzt oder bei jeder Transaktion, ob das jetzt Schweinehälften sind oder Geldscheine oder was auch immer, mindestens zwei Risiken und zwar das Kreditrisiko und das Liquiditätsrisiko. Also Kredit, der hat einfach dann wirklich, der bringt das wirklich nicht auf die Reihe. Und Liquiditätsrisiko, gut, der kriegt es jetzt gerade nicht auf die Reihe. Und diese Risiken soll zunächst eigentlich mal nur auf die Teilnehmer der Transaktion beschränkt sein. Also angenommen ich fünf Ochsen gegen, was weiß ich, eine Kutsche aus. Und dann wird das nichts mit den fünf Ochsen. Dann sollten eigentlich nur wir beide daran Schaden nehmen.
Na eigentlich soll ja keiner daran Schaden nehmen.
Na ja, doch, doch, doch. Das lässt sich nicht ganz vermeiden, dass wenn jemand nicht bezahlen kann, dass dann irgendjemand auch daran Schaden nimmt. Jetzt gibt es aber das Problem, dass über diese Parteien hinaus halt auch andere hineingezogen werden können, sobald sich eine Währungseinheit namens Geld da einspielt. Dann kann es nämlich also sogenannte Spillovers in andere Bereiche geben und dann haben wir das, was man so gerne als systemisches Risiko bezeichnet. Nämlich angenommen eine Bank fällt jetzt halt quasi gegen das mit den Wirtschaften nicht so ganz gut und danach hat das zunächst mal nur, sollte man denken, Auswirkung auf die Kunden dieser Bank. Ja, aber angenommen, dass das jetzt noch die Korrespondenzbank einer anderen Bank, dann hat die andere Bank auch ein Problem und dann dann heben deren Kunden wiederum, wie dumm, dann kommt die nächste Bank, deren Kunden alle Geld abheben, weil sie denken, oh jetzt geht ja jetzt fällt ja alles um. Dadurch, dass dann alle Kunden Geld abheben, ist kein Geld mehr dabei und so weiter und so weiter. Also das System ist relativ offensichtlich.
Deswegen freuen wir uns, dass das eine Bank macht, von der wir wissen, dass da kleinere Geldbestände doch noch im Keller lagern.
Naja, aber genau, warum lagern diese Geldbestände im Keller? Da fängt es halt schon genau an. Also für herkömmliches Geld, sag ich mal, gibt es halt eine Regelierung, es gibt eine Bankenaufsicht, es gibt, um genau diesen Risiken, die ich eben kurz erwähnt habe, im Gegen zu steuern, gibt es diverse Gegenmaßnahmen. Das eine sind Mindestreserven, also 10% muss ich mindestens von dem Geld, das ich auslange, muss ich dann wirklich auch real haben als Bank. Und das andere sind versicherte Accounts, versicherte Konten. Das heißt, selbst wenn meine Bank pleite geht, bin ich ja eigentlich versichert und eigentlich wird alles nicht so schlimm. Das Problem ist natürlich, dass genau wegen dieser Versicherung nur ein geringerer Anreiz besteht, dann auch tatsächlich die Sicherheit wirklich sicherzustellen, weil ja alles versichert ist durch Parteien, die ich nicht finanzieren muss oder nur zu einem kleinen Teil. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, sobald ich dann E-Cash habe, wo sind wir denn jetzt da angenommen? Angenommen, eine Bank könnte das frei von jeglicher Regulierung ausgeben, etc. kann ich plötzlich unendliche Mengen von Geld generieren. Und ja, dann ist plötzlich mal diese unendlichen Mengen von Geld angenommen, das System wäre nicht sicher, dann kann die Bank gar nicht feststellen, wenn sie jetzt mit Forderungen konfrontiert wird, was jetzt wirklich davon echt ist und was nicht. Ist ja dummerweise alles digital. Und dann stell ich mir plötzlich die Frage, dumm, müssen wir mal aufhören, dieses Geld anzunehmen. Ja, und dann haben wir unzahlvoll auch weniger Bargeld, weil ja alle sich an das digitale Geld gewöhnt haben und dann haben wir plötzlich da mal einen Stopp der Wirtschaft. Ja, also das sind so die kleinen, die kleinen.
Na ja, man kann es vielleicht mal von außen betrachten. Sie sehen, scheitern eigentlich alle Leute, die eine Technologie neu auf den Markt bringen. Der erste scheitert und dann kommt jemand und macht es billig nach. Und letztendlich glaube ich wäre am besten, wenn die Bundesbank das macht. Aber die Bundesbank traut sich sowas nicht. Die sind eben nicht innovativ, das sind halt Banker. Die gucken sich das an und wenn das bei jemandem anderen funktioniert, dann machen die das eben. Und deswegen ist es wichtig, dass jemand wie die Deutsche Bank macht, weil bei denen weiß man, dass da viele, viele Leute nur dafür angestellt sind, laut Scheiße zu schreien, wenn sie glauben, dass irgendwas nicht läuft. Das heißt, da ist so ein gewisser Name eben dahinter, dass man sagen kann, na, da wird schon was dran sein. Und wenn es jetzt ein bisschen gut geht bei der Deutschen Bank, dann wird sich das sicher in andere Bereiche propagieren. Und eine Sache, die an der Stelle sehr wichtig ist, ist die Patentfrage. Denn eCash ist in seiner jetzigen Form patentiert. Das heißt, man muss Litenzgebühren zahlen, aber Patente gelten nicht ewig und die Patente auch. Das heißt, in acht Jahren, Pluto, richtig? Genau, 2008 laufen die Patente aus. Und wenn wir bis dahin ein bisschen rumspielen, also genügend mit eCash rumspielen, genügend Testversuche, genügend so ein bisschen Liveversuche haben, wo sagen wir mal eine hundert Leute teilnehmen, um das überhaupt am Leben zu halten bis 2008, dann haben wir dann die Möglichkeit, dass eben ohne Lizenzgebühren, das heißt für jedermann wunderbar eCash auf dem Markt sein kann. Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass es jetzt überhaupt jemand macht und dass die Deutsche Bank macht, wenn nicht nicht schlecht an der Stelle, weil das ist besser als wenn es die, was weiß ich, Baumschuhe in Sparkasse hinter Tupfingen macht und die dann irgendwie 2004 Pleite macht und dann denken alle, das war kein eCash.
Ja, was in den USA ja auch schon so halt passiert ist, also der erste Herausgeber von eCash war halt Mark Twain Bank. Das ist so ein kleiner Zusammenschluss von so ein paar Sparkassen, ähnlichen Geschäftsbanken aus der Provinz in den USA. Die haben das halt auch nicht lange durchgehalten. Nachher haben wir auch dementsprechend die Marktweite, die eine Deutsche Bank zum Beispiel hat. Also was zum Beispiel diese Patentfrage ist, ist halt für die Bundesbank auch ein ganz harbes Problem, weil auf Drucken gibt es keine echten Patente. Das wurde vor 500 Jahren erfunden. Und jetzt besonders gut drucken zu können, also sichere Geldscheine zu drucken, ist auch nicht wirklich patentiert. Sie wissen nicht, dass ich jetzt wüsste. Und das kann ich halt als Staat benutzen. Da mache ich mich halt nicht mit einem von mir garantierten Zahlungsmittel von einer kleinen amerikanischen Firma abhängig, sondern benutze einfach Technik, die frei zur Verfügung steht. Jetzt, wenn die Bundesbank jetzt E-Cash ausgeben würde, dann würde sie sich halt abhängig machen von genau dieser Patentfrage, sprich sie macht ein garantiertes Zahlungsmittel und in einem Jahr sagt E-Cash Technologies in den USA so mit euch her und dann müssen sie plötzlich ihr garantiertes Zahlungsmittel wieder einstellen. Das ist natürlich eine Situation, wo man als Staat irgendwie mit so einer kleinen Firma in den USA mit 20 Angestellten und dann sagen die einem, was man darf und was nicht. Haja, also das hat schon so gewisse irgendwie Berührungsängste.
Ich dachte das wäre eh schon so.
Das ist geheim.
In dem Fall kennt man halt den Firmennamen, deswegen haben sie die Berührungsangst, also wenn man nicht weiß, wer das ist. Also wenn der Königsmacher unbekannt ist, ist der König mächtiger.
Ja die sollen das ruhig mal noch 10 Jahre vor sich hin testen, bis wirklich das letzte Patent ausgelaufen ist und damit alles gut.
Apropos geheim, was war das eben für eine Verschwörungstheorie, die du noch machen wolltest, Andreas?
Verschwörungstheorie? Jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr welche Verschwörungstheorie.
Das war gar keine Theorie, das war alles die Wahrheit.
EDS, genau EDS.
Achja, eine kurze Sache.
Haben wir nicht noch einen Hörer in der Leitung?
Eine kurze Sache, genau eine kurze Sache. E-Cast.
Dann müssen wir noch mindestens verabschieden, oder?
Achso, den haben wir schon. Der hat sich schon selbst verabschiedet gehabt.
Also einen ist das noch wegen E-Cast, bevor irgendjemand das als Verschwörungstheorie bringt. Man kann bei uns, ist das jetzt schon, oder demnächst mit E-Cast spenden. Dem CTC, ja, also da freuen wir uns auch nicht nur drüber, weil wir gerne E-Cast pushen, sondern da könnt ihr auch testen, ob das auch klappt mit dem E-Cast. Ja, macht das mal alle schön. Und immer her mit der Kohle, wir machen dann damit. Wir finanzieren damit wunderbare Radiosendungen.
Wie kommt denn die Deutsche Bank da eigentlich an mein Geld? Gehe ich da hin und leg den Zehner auf den Tisch und die geben mir irgendwie einen Zettel in die Hand?
So ungefähr funktioniert das. Es gibt dann ein sogenanntes Pool-Konto. Das heißt, alle E-Cash-Inhaber benutzen dasselbe Konto, auf das sie Geld überweisen. Das wird dann aus dem Pool-Konto rausgenommen. Du hast eine Software auf deinem Rechner, die diese Münzen generiert, also diese Umschläge ausfüllt und dahinschickt und wieder zurückschickt. Also du musst vorher Geld auf das Konto überwiesen haben, kannst dann mit der Software dir die Münzen abholen, kannst dann damit bezahlen.
Ja, es gibt dann mittlerweile auch ein weiteres Feature. Also dieses Pool-Konto ist abgesehen davon auch ein Problem, weil bis jetzt haben wir ja nur darüber geredet, was da alles schön dran ist. Also das Pool-Konto hat den großen Vorteil, dass das Geld da halt auch anonym liegt, also sprich, es kann nicht zugeordnet werden, also es ist kein Schattenkonto, sondern nur ein Account im sogenannten Mint. Und da kann man mittlerweile auch per Lastschrift, also aus dem Wallet, also aus seiner Geldbörse, die man so auf seinem Rechner hat, mit ein paar Klicks untertanen, kann man dann irgendwie 100 Mark auf seinen E-Cash-Account transferieren. Und das geht dann auch in dem Augenblick, als wenn man jetzt zahlen möchte und irgendwie das Geld sofort braucht, dann geht das seit Neuestem auch sofort. Also da findet auch eine Weiterentwicklung statt, die sich halt auch durch die Userbase definiert.
Chaosradio 48 zum Thema, was? E-Geld? E-Cash? E-Elektron?
E-Cash.
Was ist mit eurer CD los? Ich weiß nicht.
Schon klar, wir sind schuld.
Na sicher.
Ich glaube es gibt die CD, ne den Jingle in zwei Varianten. Du hast ihn ja verlaufen lassen.
Nein, das ist eure Schuld.
Wäre das erste Mal, na gut, das erste Mal seit dem Mittagessen.
Hat sich spezifikationsgemäß verhalten die CD?
Was ich eben fragte als die Musik lief, war eine hundertprozentige Sicherheit, dass nicht die Deutsche Bank weiß, dass ich bestimmte Dinge mit bestimmtem Geld, was sie mir gegeben haben, kaufe. Ist nicht gegeben.
Also solange du Software von der Deutschen Bank einsetzt, können die da natürlich ein Ei reingelegt haben. Theoretisch. Keine Frage. Man muss sich fragen, hätten die da ein Interesse daran, haben die überhaupt den Quellcode gesehen oder haben die das einfach direkt gekauft? So dürfte überhaupt was ändern und eine Sache, die wir ja gehört haben, ist, dass die den Quellcode gar nicht gesehen haben, sondern dass der direkt aus USA kommt, die Binaries direkt, das heißt, selbst die Deutsche Bank, wenn sie gewollt hätte, hätten sie das dann nicht einbauen können. Das wäre natürlich unter anderen verschwörungstheoretischen Gesichtspunkten eher schlecht. Aber so theoretisch, ja, könnte da was drin sein.
Also wir kritisieren natürlich schon, dass es den Source Code nicht gibt für den Kleinen, dass man nicht nachgucken kann, dass er nicht doch drin ist. Es muss ja nicht mal böse Absicht sein. Meistens ist es ein kleiner Bug, den man da drin hat. Zum Beispiel bei HBCI gab es eine Weile lang das Problem, dass derjenige, der es dann implementiert hat, nicht wusste, dass man bei RSA Zahlen nehmen sollte, die größer als die Wurzel aus der Keygröße sind. Und sonst kann man einfach direkt errechnen, was da rauskommt. Und naja, so was kann halt immer mal passieren, solange man den Source Code nicht hat, kann das Protokoll einem für sich sicher sein, es kann trotzdem irgendein Problem darin sein. Also ein weiteres Problem ist auch die Schlüssellänge, die da verwendet wird, die ist 768 Bit. Und 512 Bit RSA sind schon geknackt worden und 768 Bit liegen mit Sicherheit in dem, was, wie wir sagen, wer die n ist, wenn sie wirklich will, erreichen kann, vielleicht auch mehr. Also letzten Endes besteht da schon noch die Möglichkeit, dass da was rauskommt. Deshalb ist, also sagen wir natürlich e-cash ist gut und dass die Deutsche Bank das macht, ist toll, aber sie könnte noch besser machen, dass der Source Code für die Programme verfügbar ist, dass die Keylängen größer sind und dass das alles wohl dokumentiert ist, wie dieses Protokoll aussieht.
Noch eine Kleinigkeit vielleicht generell für Security und Kryptographie gilt, wenn ich mein Leben lang nie irgendwas verschlüssel und dann die eine Transaktion doch verschlüssel, dann ist das natürlich gleich viel verdächtiger, als wenn ich grundsätzlich alles verschlüssel. Das heißt, was ich damit sagen will, wenn wir jetzt immer mit Kreditkarte einkaufen, sag ich jetzt mal bei Amazon oder sonst wo mir irgendwas kaufe und dann zahl ich immer mit Kreditkarte und die eine Transaktion im Jahr irgendwie bei, was weiß ich, strapazieren wir jetzt wieder Porno, mach ich dann eben doch mit E-Cash, dann ist natürlich die Anonymität auch an der Stelle eingeschränkt. Deswegen, wenn man so eine Kryptographie zum Schutz von irgendwelchen Werten wie Anonymität oder Privatsphäre benutzt, dann aber auch so weit wie geht und nicht nur dann, wenn man es wirklich anonyme haben möchte.
Wir haben jetzt doch gefunden den Fintech, ich würde sagen.
Genau, der Fintech heißt nämlich EDS, Electronic Data Systems. Das ist eine Firma, die relativ wenige Leute kennen, die aber ziemlich groß ist und ich glaube der größte EDV-Dienstleister weltweit. Vor IBM, nach IBM, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Auf jeden Fall, viele Firmen betreiben ja Outsourcing, das heißt sie betreiben ihre Rechner gar nicht selbst, sondern lassen die betreiben, lassen ihre Daten von jemandem dritten verwalten. Und zu den Unternehmen, die sowas tun, gehören zum Beispiel Visa. Das heißt, wenn ich in Deutschland mit einer Visa-Karte, die ich von einer deutschen Bank bekommen habe, eine Transaktion tätige, dann wird das in den USA gespeichert auf einem Rechner, der nicht unter Kontrolle meiner Bank steht, auch nicht unter Kontrolle von Visa, sondern unter Kontrolle von EDS. Das heißt, da gilt schon mal das deutsche Datenschutzrecht nicht. Und zum zweiten hat da eine Firma drauf Zugriff, die da möglicherweise auch andere Interessen haben. Firma EDS betreibt nämlich zum Beispiel auch das EDV-System für die amerikanische Einwanderungsbehörde und für die amerikanische Verkehrszulassung und für viele Fluggesellschaften und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, die sind letzten Endes in der Lage, Daten zusammenzuführen, die für sich betrachtet harmlos werden, die dann aber in einer Kombination doch wieder Aussagen über die Bibarsphäre machen. Also so viel zitiertes Beispiel, ja, also das macht ja gar nicht, wenn wir das speichern, weil das weiß ja gar keiner, wem das wirklich gehört. Aber dadurch, dass letzten Endes diese Rechner von nur einer Firma betrieben werden, die für viele andere Firmen arbeitet, ist die Möglichkeit der Zusammenführung dieser Daten dann doch gegeben. Also wenn ich jetzt mal einen Amerika Urlaub mache, dann bin ich eigentlich komplett die ganze Zeit nur im Rechner der Firma EDS. Da flieg ich hin, da bin ich im Flugsystem von EDS und dann komm ich da zur Grenze und werde in einem EDS Computer geprüft, ob ich vielleicht schon mal eine Straftatat begangen habe oder nicht, ob ich da einreisen darf oder nicht im Wesentlichen. Wenn ich dann unterwegs bin und mein Hotel und das Auto mit Kreditkarte bezahle, wissen das auch und irgendwann fliege ich wieder nach Hause, dass die Firma meinen Aufenthalt da komplett überwachen kann und auch beliebig manipulieren kann. Also wenn die dann irgendwann zu dem Entschluss kommen, dass ich vielleicht Firmeninteressen schade oder sowas, dann können sie ja mal aus Versehen einen Datenbank-Eintrag löschen und dann kann ich nicht mehr einreisen oder nicht mehr ausreisen oder meine Kreditkarte ist plötzlich gesperrt und so weiter und so fort.
Also da gibt es auch Zwischenstufen. Ganz witziger Nick Dota hat mal einen Auftraggeber von mir betroffen. Es gibt da eine Liste von Leuten, die von den Flughäfen-Security-Leuten genervt werden. Wenn die eingereist werden, dann werden die immer untersucht, müssen immer ihren Koffer auspacken, müssen den immer auftun, müssen irgendwie eine halbe Stunde da eine totale körperliche Untersuchung über sich ergehen lassen. Und da kommt man rauf, wenn irgendwie zufällig mal ausgewählt wurde und ob da nun tatsächlich Zufall eine Rolle spielt oder nicht, weiß man nicht. Aber die Legende ist eben, dass es irgendwie vom Geheimdienst gewartet und wenn man da dann anruft, kommt man da wieder runter. Aber wir sagen, das ist nicht alles schwarz-weiß. Also wenn die einen ein bisschen ärgern wollen, dann müssen die einem nicht gleich die Einreize verweigern, aber sie können einem sehr viel Stress machen.
Gibt es irgendwas Vergleichbares hier?
Neu Idee. Es ist natürlich auch in Deutschland tätig, so ist es ja nicht.
Ja, das ist natürlich nicht besser, wenn das nicht Visa, sondern American Express macht. Weil die machen das halt intern, aber das ist ja, heißt ja nicht, dass sie das nie auch weiterverkaufen.
Oder die Eurocard von der Citibank.
Genau, also man kann vielleicht auch sagen, Visa ist noch eher unkritisch im Vergleich zu dem, was gewisse andere Gesellschaften da mit ihren Daten bekannterweise machen, denn American Express hat als Firmenziel nicht mehr die Kreditvergabe an Leute, die eine Karte von ihnen haben, sondern die haben als Firmenziel, dass sie die Daten weiterverkaufen und so Profiterwirtschaften. Das heißt, die haben sich das tatsächlich zu Ziel gemacht, man ist nicht so hintenrum. Also Visa ist noch eher unkritisch unter den Kreditkarten.
Ja und durch diese Unsicherheit der Kreditkarten sind auch die Kreditkartenfirmen förmlich dazu gezwungen, Profile von den Leuten zu erstellen. Also deren Aussage ist im Wesentlichen ja, also nun wir wissen Kreditkarten sind nicht sicher, aber wir haben da ein tolles System, das die Kaufgewohnheiten der Leute analysiert. Wenn eine Transaktion gegen diese Kaufgewohnheiten verstößt, dann wird sie als interessant oder möglicherweise Missbrauch gepflegt und dann wird dann erst mal genauer hingeguckt und dann muss man anfangen Fragen zu beantworten, ein bisschen zur Name der Mutter und so weiter und so fort, was da alles gespeichert ist, um zu überprüfen, ob das auch tatsächlich echt ist. Also anstatt da gleich ein richtiges System zu machen, das von vorne rein sicher ist, wie zum Beispiel E-Cash, wird da die Sicherheit hintenrum durch die Abschaffung der Privatsphäre, durch genaue Analyse der Daten erreicht. Wenn man die Daten schon mal rumzulegen hat, so was sind die Einkaufsgewohnheiten desjenigen, dann kann man die natürlich auch gleich gewinnbringend weiterverkaufen. Also mit Kreditkarten zu bezahlen ist wirklich extrem unattraktiv. Und das betrifft ja nicht nur Kreditkarten, sondern das betrifft auch andere Zahlungsweisen, die in Deutschland verbreiteter sind, also wenn man mit E-C-Karten an der Tanke zahlt oder wenn man mit E-C-Karten im Internet zahlt, wenn man per Lastschrift zahlt und so weiter und so fort, das führt alles zu derselben Datenspur. Und je mehr man elektronisch tut, je mehr man digital tut, desto nachvollziehbar werden diese Datenspuren.
Wenn ich auf Rechnungszahle ist, ist es auch dasselbe. Außer ich benutze E-Cash. Obwohl, wenn ich mir was bestelle, ist es auch wurscht.
Ja, wenn deine Hand, ne nicht direkt, also die Frage ist, wer wertet das aus? Also wenn der kleine Hanswerk Betrieb oder der Pizza Versand, wenn der weiß, was für eine Pizza du gerne magst, dann werden sie das kaum der Konkurrenz verkaufen. Aber die Bank, für die Bank sind die anderen Pizza Leute keine Konkurrenten. Das heißt, wenn da Datenspuren bei der Bank anfallen, dann ist das für die nicht geschäftsschädigend, die weiter zu verkaufen. Im Gegenteil.
Also es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob ich nur, wenn ich mit einem Händler zu tun habe, dann weiß der nur das über mich, was für diese Transaktion spezifisch sind. Also zum Beispiel, welche Pizza ich mag. Aber die Bank weiß über mich, was ich im Monat verdiene, was ich für ein Auto fahre, wo ich gerne einkaufen gehe, ob ich vielleicht mal gelegentlich in einer anderen Stadt bin, ob ich dahin fliege oder mit der Bahn hinfahre.
Welche Zeitung ich abonniert habe.
Ja, also man merkt das auch, wenn man mal in der Bahnfiliale ist und sagt, hier ja meine EC-Karte gesperrt, dann gucken die einmal auf den Monitor und fangen einem die schlechten Lebensgewohnheiten vorzuwerfen und das will man eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Felix würde gerne seine eigene Bank aufmachen.
Ich hab nämlich gelesen, dass echte Verbrecher keine Bank ausrauben, sondern eine aufmachen und deswegen möchte ich jetzt eine Bank aufmachen.
Also wenn du das was schnell haben möchtest, dann gehst du nach Antigua, da brauchst du noch nicht mal anlesen zu sein zur Gründung der Bank. Ja, Board of Directors ist auch nicht wirklich nötig, Papiere einzureichen, von wegen irgendwie, dass man das schon mal gemacht hat, ist auch nicht nötig. Und das ist unter Strafe verboten, Informationen über Kunden rauszurücken. Also das CIA World Report weist sie aus, als sie leben von Geldwäsche und sonst nichts. Also sie haben diesen World Report übrigens so viel zum Thema lokale Kopien von irgendwie Internet-Salz. Also wenn man sich diesen Report aus 97 noch heute noch mal anguckt, dann steht da drin, dass die Insel irgendwie hauptsächlich von Tourismus und den Badestränden lebt. Gleicher Report, gleiches Jahr, es ist faszinierend. Und da, na ich weiß nicht so kurz, wir haben jetzt irgendwie gesagt, ja das kann irgendwie eine ganze Menge, das ist auch eine ganze Menge gut und das ist anonym und sonstiges, aber was für Probleme haben wir da dann noch? Also eins Problem ist zum Beispiel die zentrale Datenbank, in der alle Münzen abgelegt werden. Also wenn das wirklich die Bundesbank machen würde, wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele Münzen ist da drauf, das ist schon ein ziemliches Holz. Also da ist zu hoffen, dass in zehn Jahren irgendwie die Rechner wirklich sehr viel schneller sind als heute, damit sie irgendwie, sagen wir mal, zehn Prozent, zwanzig Prozent des Bargeldflusses in Deutschland irgendwie tatsächlich handeln könnten von der Zahl der Münzen, weil für jeden Zahlungsvorgang eine neue Münze generiert wird und die muss halt in die Datenbank und muss da wieder verglichen werden. Und das ist dann halt für dieses eine Zahlungssystem eine Datenbank. Ich weiß nicht, wie weit man das dann noch distributen kann, aber das ist schwierig.
Aber da gibt es ganz tolle Verfahren, um Datenbanken zu verteilen. Da habe ich nicht wirklich Sorgen, weil es gibt da irgendwie ganz andere Anforderungen, so von der größten Ordnung her. So Kryptografie kann man eigentlich perfekt verteilen, das Einzige, was echt ein Problem wäre, wäre der Lookup in der Datenbank. Und wenn man sich Alta Vista zum Beispiel anguckt, wie viele Lookups die so pro Sekunde haben, mit nur einer Alphara, das kann man wunderbar parallelisieren, denke ich mal, weil das Einzige, was wirklich ein Problem ist, sind die Schreibzugriffe und die fühlt man dann eben auf allen aus. Also das geht, das ist mit heutiger Technik kein Thema.
Was mich viel mehr interessiert, sind die Möglichkeiten, die sich aus dem E-Cash-Protokoll ergeben, weil ich kann nicht anfangen Geldscheine zu drucken, weil das Equipment um Geldscheine zu drucken doch sehr, sehr teuer ist, aber ich könnte zum Beispiel hingehen und anfangen, eine eigene E-Cash-Währung herauszugeben. Und das mit dem Geld ist ja immer so eine schwierige Geschichte. Früher gab es da die Goldreserve, das heißt irgendwie der Geldschein, den ich hatte, der war equivalent zu einem Stückchen Gold. Und das ist ja nun heutzutage mehr oder weniger je nach Land weggefallen. Also in manchen Ländern nicht vollständig, sondern es ist ja nicht mehr komplett da. Und jetzt frage ich mich, wie das aussieht, nehmen wir mal an, ich möchte eine eigene Internetwährung einführen, wie würde ich denn so was machen?
Naja, ich muss mal eine Software schreiben.
Ja, nehmen wir mal an, ich hätte eine Software.
Du musst für jedes soziale Problem eine technische Lösung geben, auf jeden Fall.
Genau, genau. Nehmen wir mal an, ich habe eine Software und das klappt auch alles ganz gut. Und ich habe auch tolle Server und tolle Admins, die sich dafür begeistern können. Und die Frage ist, wie kriege ich das, wie kriege ich das ökonomisch hin, dass so eine Währung funktioniert?
Ich sag mal, wir gehen jetzt erstmal von der ganzen komplizierten rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen, die lassen wir mal außen vor. Wir gehen mal davon aus, wie wir leben auf Robinsons Insel. Da haben wir aber gleich das erste Problem, selbst wenn es da keine Gesetze gäbe, soll es aber zumindest ein paar Menschen da geben, sonst macht das Ganze nämlich keinen Sinn. Was ist erstmal die grundlegende Voraussetzung für irgendein Zahnungssystem, damit das irgendwie attraktiv wird? Na ja, es muss von den teilnehmenden Parteien irgendwie als sicher, wertbeständig, kurz als ein abstraktes System angesehen werden, der man mal kurz seine Ersparnisse anvertraut. Deswegen hat man auch in Zeiten von Innovationen tendenziell das Problem, dass gewisse Währungen dann ganz schnell verlassen werden.
Na ja, die Leute legen ihre Gelder als Lotto an und irgendwie...
Na ja, aber ihr ganzes Vermögen halt eben doch nicht, ne?
Nun ja, haben schon Leute ihr Vermögen echt in Sand investiert. Ich hab da noch so ein Kunststück in Florida.
Also das ist schon mal das erste, die erste Voraussetzung. Es muss einfach mal ein... Also letztendlich ist Geld ja auch nichts anderes als institutionalisiertes Vertrauen. Also im Prinzip, wenn man sich das ganze mal aus dem Weltraum so anguckt, was die Menschen so machen hier auf diesem Planeten, ist es ja schon ein bisschen albern, ja. Die tauschen irgendwie bunte bedruckte Papiere aus und zwischendurch auch noch Eisen und Metall. Also es ist schon sehr interessant und dann jagen sie nach und zwischendurch geben sie das mal von einer an die andere. Das ist ja schon alles ganz abstrakt. Warum macht man sowas? Also es würde ja noch, wäre noch vor wenigen hundert Jahren keinem eingefallen, sowas irgendwie vertrauen zu setzen. Deswegen Vertrauen ist eigentlich das Beste des Wortes, der Anfang von allem. Und dann die eigentliche Implementation, das kann man beliebig komplex machen. Wir fangen einfach an in einer sehr einfachen Wirtschaft an. Wir sollten halt eine gewisse kritische Masse an Leute haben. Und dann ist halt die Frage, wie wollen wir diese Risiken, diese Risiken eindämmen, was ich eben schon mal angesprochen hab, dieses systemische Risiko. Also es ist auch die Frage, wollen wir eigentlich eine Regulierung eines Zahlungssystems durch eine zentrale Stelle? Im Prinzip wäre es ja schön, wenn es das alles dezentral regeln ließ. Es gibt halt nur dieses kleine moralische Problem, dass sobald ich anfange halt, wie eben gesagt, bestimmte Konten zu versichern, hat keiner Anreiz in Sicherheit bis zu dem Level zu investieren, wo es effizient wäre. Und wenn ich es nicht tue, wenn ich die Accounts nicht versichere, dann habe ich aber das Problem, dass unter Umständen der Zusammenbruch einer Bank, also einer geldausgebenden Institution, damit fängt es ja an, dann unter Umständen ganz fiese Auswirkungen auf die gesamte Robinsonische Insel hat. Also diese ganze Geldgeschichte fing ja im Prinzip damit an, dass die Goldschmiede früher das Geld aufbewahrt haben, haben sich immer gedacht, da gehen die Leute immer auf Reisen. Ich gebe ihnen dann ein Papier mit. Ja hier, der Herr H. Acker hat bei mir so und so viel Kilo Gold hinterlegt. Ich gebe ihm hier ein Schreiben an meinen Freund, ein paar Städte weiter, dass ich das Geld hier habe und er soll ihm das geben. Er weiß ja, mir traut er ja und ich hab das dann hier für ihn aufbewahrt. Und dann irgendwann kamen natürlich die Leute auf die Idee, die Leute sind ständig unterwegs, hier liegt tierisch viel Geld bei mir rum, da muss man noch was draus machen können. Dann fingen sie halt an dieses Geld auszuleihen, weil sie ja wussten, es kommt nie vor, dass alles Geld gleichzeitig abgeholt wird. Deswegen kann man das Geld gegen Zins, haha, hier kommen auch schon wieder alle Fiesigkeiten des Lebens direkt ins Spiel, können wir ausleihen und so weiter und so fort. Die einzige interessante Frage im ganzen System ist eigentlich fast, wie viel Prozent des Geldes, also des real vorhandenen Geldes, da wird es schon wieder kompliziert, leht man zu welchen Konditionen und an welche Risikoklassen aus? Und genau hier fängt es halt an, also wenn ich mein ganzes Geld verleihen kann, habe ich natürlich ein sehr hohes Risiko und kann auch aus, durch das Verleihen des verliehenden Geldes, das wiederum verliehen ist, kann ich halt neues Papiergeld schöpfen, auch wenn die eigentliche Goldmenge sich da nicht ändert. Naja, das war jetzt die Frage, Mindestreserven ist eigentlich eine sinnvolle Einrichtung. Werden jetzt schon die ersten Fragen, die wir diskutieren müssten, würden wir sowas wollen, würden wir sowas machen wollen. Auch Banken wollten wir das regulieren. Kann halt jeder Goldspiel das machen oder nicht. Also im Prinzip kann man ja eigentlich keinen, also kann man natürlich schon, aber im Prinzip sollte man ja a priori dann können müssen, dass er einfach anfängt irgendwelche Geldeinheiten oder Werteinheiten mit seinen Freunden da zu tauschen. Also manche tauschen Briefmarken, andere tauschen irgendwie Abziehbilder. Warum sollen andere nicht irgendwie komische, bedruckte, quadratische oder rechteckige Scheine tauschen?
Ja, das mit dem Tauschhandel ist im Prinzip auch der Anfang von dem ganzen gewesen. Also selbst das Gold war schon ein Abstraktionswert auf das, was getauscht wurde. Sprich, solange die Leute irgendwie rumgelaufen sind und Kühe gegen Hafer getauscht haben, war alles noch einfach. Dann kam halt etwas, was so selten war, dass es als Tauschmittel, als allgemein gültiges Tauschmittel benutzt werden konnte, zum Beispiel Gold. Davon gab es halt so wenig, dass man sagen konnte, okay, du gibst mir eine Kuh, ich gebe dir ein Stück Gold. Gibt, ist halt sichergestellt, dass du jetzt nicht aus diesem einen Goldstück irgendwie plötzlich 1000 Goldstücke machst und dir davon irgendwie eine ganze Haferfabrik kaufen kannst. Und aus dieser Abstraktion von Tauschhandel ist dann irgendwann, wie du gesagt hast, ein Goldschmiede halt irgendwie das Papiergeld und das, was wir heute kennen und die ganzen Geldmengen, die dahinterstehen, entstanden. Also wenn man jetzt eine eigene Währung aufmachen möchte, dann muss man halt erstmal was haben, womit man anfängt zu tauschen. Wenn man jetzt sagen würde, wir wollen eine Währung machen, die sich zum Beispiel auf Arbeitsleistung basiert, dann könnte man sagen, okay, jeder, der jetzt da anfängt, legt zum Beispiel als Startguthaben 100 Stunden Programmierleistung in der Programmiersprache seiner Wahl ein. Dafür erhält er irgendwie 100 kleine Dateien, die für diesen Wert halt gerade stehen. Und andere Leute können diese Dateien halt auch zwischen einander tauschen und kriegen dafür halt einen realen Wert zurück. Das heißt, dass die Programmierleistung, was immer man als Garantiewert dahinterlegt, ist dann das, was diese Dateien zu einem Wert macht, der tauschbar ist, der Sinn macht irgendwie, dagegen andere Sachen zum Beispiel. Was weiß ich, ich tausche halt irgendwie drei Stunden Programmieren gegen irgendwie ein gutes, der selbst gemacht ist, DJ-Tape, wäre dann halt irgendwie drei Stunden Steinchen gegen irgendwie zwei, gegen einen Tape, weil für das Tape hat der Typ etwa genauso lang gebraucht bei einem ähnlichen Qualifikationslevel und damit hat man dann schon so eine ähnliche Währung.
Du wolltest noch was zu peer to peer?
Ich würde gerne erstmal beim Geld laden, weil ich finde zum Beispiel diese Frage des Geldverleihens ziemlich interessant und ist das denn zwangsläufig notwendig, könnte ich nicht zum Beispiel sagen, dass ich, wenn ich Geld verleihe, das Geld grundsätzlich haben muss oder wäre es nicht auch denkbar, irgendwie anders zu verhindern, dass große Mengen Gold gehortet werden, wenn man zum Beispiel einen Negativzins auf das Geld erhebt, also das Geld regelmäßig entwertet?
Naja, das passiert doch automatisch. Also wenn du einfach sagst, dass du kannst nur das verleihen, was du wirklich hast, das ist natürlich eine ganz radikale Methode, aber dann ist es auch schlecht, denn du willst im Prinzip den Leuten schon die Möglichkeit geben, einfach Kredite aufzunehmen, weil du dadurch auch Wachstum schaffen kannst, wenn du keine Kredite geben kannst, weil es nur so und so viele Klötzchen da sind, hast du irgendwann ein Wachstumsproblem. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen gewagt, der Sprung jetzt direkt darüber, aber einer der Gründe, warum die Währungen heute halt nicht mehr auf dem Goldstandard basieren, denn die absolute Menge an Gold auf diesem Planeten ist halt dann doch begrenzt und wenn man immer noch nach dem System, ich lasse die Begriffe jetzt raus, wenn man immer noch nach dem Goldstandard gehen würde, hätte man irgendwann mal ein Problem mit dem Wachstum.
Wozu bräuchten wir denn das Wachstum?
Das ist irgendwie eine der Grundideen dieser ganzen komischen kapitalistischen Gesellschaft, dass es irgendwie ein jährliches Wachstum von zwei bis drei Prozent geben muss, sonst geht irgendwie...
Nee, das ist einfach mal ein ganz menschiges Bedürfnis von dir, weil du den gleichen Acker bearbeitest. Also wenn ich jetzt mal auf die wesentlichen Dinge runtergehe und du kriegst dann irgendwann in ein paar Jährchen mehr als eine Person auf diesem Acker.
Ja, das ist schon klar. Also der Mensch treibt halt nach Verbesserung seine Lebensumstände irgendwie, will ein größeres Auto, eine größere Wohnung, irgendwie mehr...
Na, du willst einfach nur Futter haben, wenn du mehr Leute auf dem gleichen Acker hast.
Ja, aber es gibt halt auch irgendwie nicht wachstumsbasierte Systeme. Es gibt zum Beispiel Ureinwohner irgendwie aus dem Urwald, die haben zum Beispiel Ackerbaumethoden entwickelt, mit denen sie in der Lage sind, im Urwald zu roden und zu ackern, ohne dass sie ein Wachstum in der Bevölkerung oder in der Ackerfläche haben, und die haben damit irgendwie 10.000 Jahre überlebt. Was ist also an diesem Kapitalismus so komplett intern krank?
Die haben keine Playstation.
Die haben auch kein Internet.
Die haben auch kein Internet, die haben Buschbäume, das funktioniert jeden Tag auch in der Stromaus. Also es gibt da irgendwie, also AppOvision ist für ein bisschen was, dass ich Gedanken lesen, also jeder hat da irgendwie seine Features, also man braucht nicht unbedingt Internet, also zum Teil kommen wir jetzt nicht, ich stelle alles hin.
Warum willst du dann trotzdem Internet?
Weil, das frage ich mich auch manchmal, aber wegen den MP3s und den Pornos ist doch klar.
Ja, das ist schon so ein Feature irgendwo, das ist wahr, das ist klar. Nee, aber das Problem mit dem Wachstumsdingster ist halt schon irgendwie die einfachen Krankheit dieser Gesellschaft, dass irgendwo dieser Kapitalismus halt darauf aufbaut, dass es irgendwie jedes Jahr drei Prozent mehr gibt, drei Prozent mehr, wenn in der Wirtschaft, die es nicht schafft, irgendwie 2, 5 bis 3 Prozent Wachstum zu bringen, gilt als krank und da fragt man sich dann natürlich schon irgendwie, wenn ich innerhalb meines begrenzten Systems lebe, wohin geht das Wachstum, weil irgendwie, wenn ich halt so Viereck von 10 mal 10 Zentimeter habe und ich mach halt jeden Tag irgendwie ein Stück davon irgendwie in einen schwarzen Punkt rein, irgendwann ist das Viereck voll.
Ja nee, nee, das ist aber genau die falsche Denke, ja. Also das ist nämlich genau das Problem. Also wenn du halt davon ausgehst, das ist irgendwann voll, das ist ja genau das, was du vermeiden willst. Um immer auf den Acker zurückzugehen, du hast irgendwie den Acker, der ändert sich nicht in der Fläche, aber du kannst ihn halt besser ausnutzen.
Ja, das Video muss man ausnutzen, um alles glücklich zu werden. Also dass wir das Ganze überhaupt haben, um dahin zu kommen, wo wir sind, dass man sich nicht irgendwie von morgens bis abends den Buckelkrumm schuften muss, um genügend Essen zu haben, ist ja eigentlich eine gute Sache. Das ist irgendwie ein alter Menschheitstraum, so das Paradies auf Erden, so ich steh morgens auf und die gebratenen Tauben fliegen mir in den Mund. Tauben da sind und das wir eigentlich gar nicht mehr Wachstum benötigen.
Also ich glaube die eigentliche Theorie ist, dass den Kindern in der Schule beigebracht wird, dass es auf der Welt Leute gibt, die andere ausbeuten und es gibt Leute, die ausgebeutet werden und die Theorie ist einfach, dass Leute glauben, dass sie...
Die muss halt zu den Richtigen gehören.
Zu den Ausbeutern gehören Leute, damit sie glücklich sind und Ausbeuter sind Leute, die Wachstum zeigen, ist doch klar, weil ansonsten hat es ja keinen Vorteil, Ausbeutender zu sein und deswegen möchten die Leute gerne Wachstum haben.
Also das heißt, auf Deutsch werden wir in einer Überflussgesellschaft leben, dann könnten wir auf diese ganze Verleihgeschichte verzichten.
Na tun wir doch oder nicht?
Da musst du dir Raumschiff Enterprise angucken. Also wenn du an Bord eines dieser komischen Raumschiffe bist, dann hast du halt Hunger, dann drückst du auf Klappchen, dann kriegst du Essen.
Da gibt's ja auch kein Geld. Angeblich.
Bei Armhautklamotten läuft's genauso. Also sprich, da hast du keine Waffen, keine Geld.
Ja, aber warum hast du einen Wappkern, den du mit Fasern mitkriegst? Irgendwelche, ah, ah, ich glaube, ich bin nicht arbeiter von Warners.
Ich fände das eine sehr bemerkenswerte Frage, weil letzten Endes wird ja heutzutage mehr und mehr von Maschinen gemacht. Also wer baut denn die Autos? Früher standen da 20.000 Leute am Fließband. Heutzutage werden das immer weniger, okay, da sind noch Menschen in der Produktion beteiligt, aber es nimmt rapide ab und es geht einfach mal dahin, dass da irgendwie einer sitzt, der klickt sich am Computer irgendwie ein Auto zusammen, dann drückt er auf den Renderknopf, dann fällt hinten aus der Fette ein Auto raus. Und wie geht man damit um?
Damit gehst du schon seit dem Weberaufstand ganz, ganz gekonnt eigentlich um das irgendwie. Guck mal deine Klamotten, die du anhast, die sind auch nicht mehr per Hand gewebt. Das ist eigentlich schon eine fiese Sache.
Ich würde es nach Konsumgütern erzeugen, damit wir auch weiter wachsen.
Diese künstliche Theorie ist ja schon sehr gewagt. Also ich meine, beweist mir mal, wenn ich dich hier mal ganz konkret frage, warum möchtest du eigentlich immer jedes Jahr oder in bestimmten fest definierten Intervallen einen neuen Computer haben? Wieso brauchst du einen fiesen externen, externen in dich rein implantierter Impuls, der sich genau nach Megahatt und Megabyte irgendwie festmacht? Das ist irgendwie...
Der Kollege von mir hat einen Sparkbook mit 32 Megabyte RAM, einem 60-Megahatt-Prozessor und der ist da extrem glücklich mit. Also ich finde schon, dass auch diese irgendwie, wir brauchen noch mehr Megahatt, teilweise auch sehr künstlich ist. Also teilweise ist es so, dass neue Technologien, neue Möglichkeiten eröffnen, aber auf andererseits auch nicht. Also mehr als 60 Fremdspro Sekunde braucht in Führung einer neuen Währung, die halt kein Wirtschaftswachstum braucht oder kein Wirtschaftswachstum fördert, dazu das Mittel ist oder wir nicht generell auf diese Geldgeschichte verzichten sollten.
Naja, man muss ja sagen, wenn wir keinen Wachstum haben oder weniger Wachstum, dann verdient der Staat weniger Steuern.
Das wäre so ein schönes Schlusswort von Nachrichten gewesen.
Nachrichten.
Rechtsextreme haben am brandenburgischen Wurizen eine Hetzjagd auf links gerichtete Jugendliche verübt. Dabei wurde ein 14-jähriger lebensgefährlich verletzt. Den Überfall, der sich bereits am 10. März ereingerte, deckte der Tagesspiegel auf. Die Polizei erklärt auf Anfrage, der wahre Sachverhalt habe sich erst später herausgestellt. Rückzug im Verkehrsverbund Berlin Brandenburg wird es zum 1. April keine Tariferhöhung geben. Der Aufsichtsrat will erst am 12. April überhöhe und Zeitpunkt entscheiden. In den nächsten 14 Tagen soll auch ein Beschluss zu den Fahrkarten für den Berliner C-Bereich fallen. Abbau. Die Deutsche Bahn will auch bei den Ausbildungsplätzen sparen. Ein Sprecher kündigte an, dass in diesem Jahr etwa 1000 Lehrlinge weniger angenommen würden als 1999. Tarifbehandlung. Die Gespräche für die 3, 15 Prozent mehr Lohn und eine Angleichung der Ortstarife. Der Osttarife, nicht der Ortstarife, der hier nicht über die Telekom.
Die sind ja hoch genug schon, die Ortstarife. Die Beamten müssen Beamter eigentlich auch Ortstarife, ist egal. Lokaltermin.
Lokaltermin. Ein Jahr nach der Bahnkatastrophe in Montblanc-Tunnel ist der Ausbruch des Feuers nachgestellt worden. Dazu setzten Feuerwehrleute einen Volvo-Lastwagen in Brand. Von einem LKW diesen Typs war das Unglück mit 39 Toten ausgegangen.
Sport.
Fußball. Das Testländerspiel Kroatien-Deutschland endete mit 1 zu 1.
Wetter.
In der Nacht bis 3 Grad, am Tag gelegentlich Regen und die Temperaturen steigen auf 10 Grad. Über den linken Fahrstreifen an der Unfallstelle vorbeigeleitet.
Ein Fritz Info und eine Sportmeldung mit Nicole Marquardt. Vielen Dank, es ist 0 Uhr und 34 Minuten. Was ist da hinten? Was wird da gestresst?
Eigentlich sind sie ja schon seit fast 20 Jahren tot. Und jetzt glauben sie auf einmal, dass sie unsterblich sind. Sonntag, 16.
Juli in der Park Nürnepuhlheide.
Ausverkauft, aber zum Glück gibt's ein Zusatzkonzert.
Samstag, 15.
Juli auch in der Wuhlheide.
Ja, ich muss aber vorher noch nochmal... also Moment, du musst vorher...
Entschuldigung, Moment noch.
Ein Spruch loswerden. Die ganze philosophische Diskussion eben ist ja alles auch schön und gut. Nur mal kurz noch das eine Statement dazu, die Wahl des Austauschmechanismus hat damit relativ wenig zu tun. Also Geld löst dieses Problem, wenn man das Problem sieht, nicht. Danke und jetzt können wir Enno rannehmen.
Okay, vielleicht ist Enno ja. Enno, bist du noch dran?
Ja, ja, bin noch dran.
Ja, dann sag doch mal.
Ich bin jetzt seit 48 Minuten dabei und versuch euch...
Kommunikation heute.
Musst du Geld schicken, kommst du auch dran. Also ganz einfach.
Ich hab ja so eine Veranstaltung von der SPD besucht und da hatten sie alle so kleine Anstecknadeln in Form eines schwarzen Koffers, wo drauf stand BIMBIS.
Völlig geil. Na los, Enno, los hier, sonst müssen wir dich rausschmeißen.
Okay, also im Internet kaufe ich eigentlich auch nicht mit Kreditkarte ein oder so, wie wahrscheinlich die meisten nicht, weil es echt unsicher ist, denke ich. Also bei Amazon oder eBay oder so, schon mal wieder was gekauft, aber dann auch nur per Rechnung. Und ich wollte mal fragen, wo Frizen liegt, was dir da immer wieder in den Nachrichten erwähnt?
Keine Ahnung, guck ins Internet.
Ja, halt diskutiert im Chat, falls ihr den irgendwie verfolgt, außer Fefe ein bisschen.
Ja, ja, wir haben uns wieder kräftig.
Ja, Fefe lacht immer und wir wundern uns alle.
Mein Monitor ist nicht in der Lage, das so gut da zu... also er ist kaputt.
Würdest du denn mehr über das Internet kaufen, wenn du anonym und sicher zahlen könntest?
Und wenn du in Wrizen wohnen würdest?
Ja, dann hast du uns ja extrem weiter geholfen, hab sich ja gelohnt die 48 Minuten.
Ja, ehrlich.
Oh, danke für deinen Anruf, tschau. Ja, hier klingelt noch was, warte mal. Hallo, wer bist denn du? Was?
Ja, und zwar, weil ich wissen, wer die Platinistin jetzt liest.
Ja, die können die Verkennung machen. Sie pipeen alle Radiostationen rein, da fällt unten eine Liste Titel raus. Vielleicht sollte man die einfach mal dazu bringen, um das auf der Webseite zu veröffentlichen.
Darum werden wir immer angefurzt, wenn wir aus Versehen immer eine falsche Platte spielen. Das kommt ja vor, dass du irgendwie Track 4 bei denen in der Histe drehst und du spielst aus Versehen Track 1. Also es kommt vor von derselben Nummer.
Nein, das heißt Track 1 extra, ja.
Das weiß ich nicht, so genau hab ich mich da doch nicht drum gekümmert.
Nee, aber dann sind die Hitlist-Fans richtig mal nicht vor dir jetzt.
Das geht ja so nicht.
So, ja, war hier noch irgendein Anruf?
Nee, grad nicht.
Na, die ist geheulich.
Aber die Musik find ich gut, die kann gut noch ein bisschen lauter.
Enno, bist du das?
War?
Du wolltest jetzt aber nicht wissen, was der Track eben war, oder?
Nee, nee, ich wollte besagen, ich tippe mal kurz in drei Sekunden Relativitätssystem.
Hi, ist der Micha.
Ach Micha.
Ja, du, am Anfang habt ihr so, am Anfang der Sendung habt ihr...
Nein! Yamakava heißt die Firma. Yama wie ein Yamaha und Kava wie die Kakaosorte.
Ja, aber ist das Verlöhren?
Das ist das Wundergerätwort.
Nee, das ist nur sehr bemerkenswert, weil wenn man sich DVD-Player von namhaften Herstellern kauft, wir nennen jetzt keine namhaften Hersteller.
Zum Beispiel mein Philips.
Zum Beispiel dein Philips, ja. Dann halten die sich an so komische Regelungen wie zum Beispiel den Region Code, das heißt dann kann man keine amerikanischen DVDs gucken und auch keine australischen. Und dann kann man mit dem Gerät auch keine MP3-CDs abspielen, weil MP3 ist ja ganz furchtbar böse.
Und du kannst auch nicht auf die Recorder aufnehmen, deine DVDs.
Genau, genau, lauter so Dinge. Und Yamakava ist halt einfach ein kleiner Atmenkan, wo man auch das Makrovision ausschalten kann und wo man alles mit abspielen kann, was sich auf Silberne entscheidend findet. Unterhalb sind sie noch billiger. Und das ist so der erste Fall, wo sich tatsächlich...
Das Internet gemoht hat...
.ein Produkt dadurch besser verkauft, dass es bessere Features hat und nicht den besseren Namen. Also Yamakava hat einfach vorher keiner gehört. Ja, finde ich auch.
Das ist Mediamarkt, oder?
Genau, Mediamarkt. Ich hab's auch schon bei Karstadt gehört, dass da aufstehen soll. Ist egal, es ist irgendwie der einzige DVD-Play, der jetzt bei 500 Mark gibt und der ist auch noch der Beste. Also, wohnt in euch?
Ihr klingelt wieder, vielleicht ist das der Enno.
Ist das der Verbraucherberater?
Enno? Nee, ist nicht Enno. Tja, dann nicht.
Er fragt sich, ob er noch anrufen soll. Da klingelt's.
Da war Motherfucker, ihr klingelt's nochmal.
Hallo?
Oh, danke schön. Vielleicht reden wir einfach so weiter.
Genau. Ja, so eigene Währung machen. Also in Prenzlberg gab's vor ein paar Jahren, das war so Anfang der 90er.
Wir sollten vielleicht für Leute außerhalb Berlin sagen, Prenzlberg ist Prenzlauer Berg, ein Bezirk aus Berlin.
Ja, so ein kleines Reservat irgendwie für Studenten und Leute, die es nicht geschafft haben wegzuziehen irgendwie. Ja, so eine der netteren Stadtteile. Und darauf gab's halt, ich weiß nicht, wenn war das genau, 93, 94, 95, so die Größenordnung, ein Projekt, in dem halt genau das versucht wurde, nämlich eigene eigene Währung schaffen, so im Sinne von wir brauchen Vaterstaat nicht, wir haben unsere eigene, wir haben hier unsere eigene, ja, in einem größeren Freundeskreis Leistungen getauscht werden können. Das nannte sich dann Knochen, gab's in einigen Galerien und auch ein paar irgendwie Ostkost und so, war im Prinzip ein Stück Papier, das halt abgestempelt wurde, das gekauft werden konnte auch und dafür konnte man dann halt in anderen Läden, in den angeschlossenen Läden einkaufen, so 5 Pfund, glaube ich, haben die da irgendwie so einen Schein verkauft. Also nicht so das eben beschriebene System, wo halt die Währung durch eine Leistung garantiert wird, dass halt gegen diese Währung auch etwas einzutauschen ist, sondern schon auch über die reguläre Währung noch mit dahinter, bloß dass halt das Ganze ja quasi selbst gemacht ist.
Warum funktioniert das nicht mehr, Herr Lien?
Irgendwie mit den Programmierleistungen ist halt wer garantiert, dass jetzt so und so viel wirklich wert ist. Also sagen wir mal, jemand geht jetzt zu Felix und kriegt da so und so viele Steinchen für so und so viel Stunden Programmierleistung von Felix oder kommt halt irgendwie, was weiß ich, zu Andreas oder Björn oder zu mir und kriegt halt irgendwie so und so viele Steinchen für ein paar Stunden, die man sich da hinsetzt und für jemanden das macht. Aber die sind halt nicht garantiert. Es gibt halt niemanden, der dann sagt, die sind halt alle gleich wert. Weil wenn ich die jetzt taue, also wenn ich hab jetzt diese Steinchen und ich hab damit einen Anspruch auf so und so viel Leistung von irgendjemand aus dieser Runde und ich tausche die jetzt mit jemand anderem, dann muss ich dem anderen auch noch quasi dazu sagen, von wem ich die habe, weil der muss sich halt angucken, bei wem er die eintauscht, von wem er wie viel wieder zurückkriegt. Weil halt irgendwie eine Stunde von dem einen programmieren, kommen halt irgendwie tausend Zeilen raus und eine Stunde von dem anderen.
Aber letztendlich hat man das Problem mit Geld ja auch. Also man kriegt ja auch dieselbe Dienstleistung für verschiedene Beträge.
Von verschiedenen Leuten und es ist ja noch verschieden viel wert.
Ja, aber in dem Fall haben wir halt hier so drei Leute, oder vier Leute, die halt für den Wert der Währung garantieren. Und alle vier haben halt irgendwie einen anderen, können einen anderen Gegenwert anliefern. Also es geht mir jetzt nicht so um dieses Beispiel, dass ich für den gleichen Schein bei dem einen irgendwie mehr DVD kriege als bei dem anderen. Sondern darum, dass derjenige, der mir garantiert, dass dieser Schein was wert ist, halt unterschiedliche Leistungen dahinter setzen kann. Der eine kann...
Na ja, er kann vor allem eine sehr begrenzte Zahl von Leistungen dahinter setzen. Das ist eigentlich der Deckpunkt.
Da musst du halt die Gruppe ausweiten. Da muss man halt sagen, alle Deutschen gemeinsam stehen mit ihrer Leistung dafür ein, dass irgendwie dieser Schein was wert ist.
Und...
und Skrava rein nannte sich das früher.
Vielleicht kann man sich mal die Geldscheine angucken, die früher durch Gold gebackt waren, das heutzutage nicht mehr sind. Vielleicht kann man damit anfangen, dass man eine Währung einführt, die erst mal equivalent zu einer existierenden Währung ist. Und wenn man die kritische Masse überschritten hat, kann man sich ja von einer Währung abkuppeln.
Naja, das Problem ist ja, wenn ich einfach jetzt, sagen wir mal, ich bringe jetzt die Pfeffedollar raus und sage das Equivalent zu Euro, dann ist es ja letztendlich eine Glaubensfrage, ob du mir glaubst, dass ich tatsächlich für jeden Pfeffedollar, den ich dir gebe, einen Euro zurückgelegt habe. Das ist doch das Problem, dass im Grunde die niemand außer mir dir das eintauschen wird, weil einfach niemand außer dir, mir wahrscheinlich, glaubt, dass ich das hinterlegt habe. Das muss schon staatlich oder irgendwie anderweit... Ja, vor allem wenn du in die Bugtürken drei Stunden von mir verkaufst, dann müsstest du ja nach dem Bugtu fahren.
Ja, und Western Union hat sie gerade auch nicht irgendwie vorrätig.
Das ist eine dumme Sache.
Das Schöne am Internet ist ja, dass ich da überall zu Hause bin.
Ja, aber trotzdem, also die Pfeffedollars sind halt nichts mehr wert, wenn Pfeffo unter den Bus kommt.
Es sei denn, dass es ausreichend deutlich die Pfeffedollars akzeptieren, also wenn sich Pfeffedollar als Tauschmittel durchgesetzt hat.
Genau, aber bis es das getan hat, gibt es eigentlich keinen Anreiz, also alles andere mal gleichgesetzt, gibt es eigentlich keinen Anreiz, Pfeffedollars anstatt von Euros zu akzeptieren.
Es sei denn, es gibt Dienstleistungen, die kann man nur gegen Pfeffedollars kaufen.
Richtig, und das müssen verdammt alternative Dienstleistungen sein, weil ich glaube einfach nicht, dass es irgendwelche Dienstleistungen gibt.
Könnte man Pfeffedollars für andere nicht haben? Zum Beispiel Dollar ist irgendwie, es gibt zwar so ein paar kleine südamerikanische Staaten, die überlegen sich gerade, ob sie den US-Dollar irgendwie den US-Amerikanischen zur Staatswährung machen, weil sie mit den eigenen Währungen nicht so richtig klarkommen. Also da gibt es durchaus Währungen, die nicht nur in einem Land gelten, sondern die zum Beispiel auch in anderen Ländern ein aktuelles Zahlungsmittel ist. Also wenn die russische Regierung irgendwelche Kosten für irgendwelche Zweitwahlen bei irgendwelchen Präsidentschaftswahlen nicht mehr in Rubeln, sondern in Dollar angibt, dann weiß man halt, dass die ein echtes Problem mit ihrer Währung haben. Und wenn man jetzt eine Internetwährung hat, die zum Beispiel von irgendjemandem gestartet wird, oder von einer größeren Gruppe gestartet wird, die mit irgendwas gebackt wird, und die sich dann in einem größeren Rahmen durchsetzt, dann hat man da schon ein echtes Feature, dass man halt sagen kann, ok, jeder der an Open Source-Projekten mitarbeitet, irgendwie Acklen-Dollar nicht bietet. Also würde zum Beispiel ja sozusagen die Open Source-Währung irgendwie auf einem E-Cash-Protokoll, das irgendwie von Cypherpunks nochmal irgendwie reimplementiert wird, aufbauen kannst. Die Frage ist halt immer das Becken und das dran Vertrauen. Aber das gleiche Problem gibt es auch bei Betriebssystemen im Sinne von eine Firma oder ein Privatschmensch, der ein Betriebssystem einsetzt, muss irgendwie dem Ding vertrauen, dass es funktioniert und er braucht einen Backer. Er braucht nicht einen Backer. Jemanden, der dahinter steht und zum Beispiel, ja für die Brötchen, das ist ja nicht alles virtuell, der dahinter steht und garantiert, dass er Support kriegt und sich das Ding weiterentwickelt.
Vor allem durch die Attraktivität ins Betriebssystem und auch mit der Masse der Nutzer halt einfach rapide zu.
Und ich hab überhaupt nichts von dem tollsten Problemen mit den Übergabestellen. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel weiß, ich hab jetzt eine Währung, die wird von allen irgendwie GPL-Programmieren akzeptiert. Ich kann damit irgendwie einkaufen gehen, ich kann damit tauschen machen, Tauschhandel machen irgendwie gegen Leistungen, gegen irgendwie Tätigkeiten, gegen sonstiges, was ja irgendwie auch ganz praktisch ist. Wenn es die Leute, wenn es mal halt was ist, wofür man zahlen sollte oder möchte oder muss oder wie auch immer, dann ist halt immer noch die Frage, wie wird der dann, der damit bezahlt wurde, für irgendwelche Custom Solutions irgendwie anhand eines solchen Tools, wie zahlt der damit seine Miete? Also bringt ihm das was, wenn er jetzt irgendwie in den GPL-Dollar irgendwie bezahlt wird, weil kann er sozusagen wecker gehen und irgendwie dafür GPL-Brötchen kaufen?
Na wahrscheinlich nicht, aber das gibt die Schildschirme doch in beide Richtungen. Also nehmen wir mal ein Netzwerk von Leuten, die zum Beispiel GPL Firewall oder ich möchte einen Maleserver, und das Problem muss gelöst werden, dann kann derjenige, der das Problem löst, über das elektronische Geld Dienstleistungen bei Open Source Programmierern einkaufen. Und wird in realem Geld bezahlt, kann sich seine Brötchen kaufen. Und im Gegenzug, wenn einer von denen irgendwann mal einen Auftrag bekommt, kann er wieder mit dem Geld, was er elektronisch bekommen hat, Dienstleistungen einkaufen. Dann kriegt er ja, der im anderen Ende der Kette sitzt, richtiges Geld und bezahlt mit elektronischem Geld weiter die Dienstleistungen, die ihm das ermöglicht.
Also eine Wechselstube. Also fängst du halt an zu sagen, okay, wir...
Die Wechselstube, keine Wechselstube, sondern eine Wechselstube, die Schrittstelle sind die Leute, die echtes Geld damit verdienen, dass sie virtuelles Geld ausgeben.
Ja, das ist aber immer die Wechselstube. Die Amerikaner gibt halt irgendwie 500 US-Dollar, dafür gibt es irgendwie auch 1000 GPL-Dollar. Und dann hast du irgendwie so eine übergreifende Währung, wo halt auch jeder in seinem Heimatland hingehen kann zu seiner lokalen Wechselstelle und sagen, ich hab hier 500 GPL-Dollar, gib mir dafür jetzt sagen wir mal 250 Mark.
Und da kommt jetzt schon grad der Punkt, gib mir dafür so und so viel Mark. Der Vorteil von so einer Sache wäre jetzt wohl, dass man das so gestalten könnte, dass man von Wechselkurs, Schwankungen, der Tauschwährung ist, könnte man relativ frei sein, weil man einfach sagt, das ist einfach eine definierte Dienstleistung. Aber das Problem ist halt, ich hab jetzt diese 100 GPL-Dollar und ich gebe sie jetzt nicht sofort aus, was ja durchaus auch mal vorkommt.
In dem Moment, wo die man damit beauftragt, Software zu entwickeln, legst du sie ja im Prinzip an. Also du kannst auch vorausschauen, denken, das und das Stück Software wird gebraucht.
Aber Geld ist ja auch halt eine wesentliche Eigenschaft von Geld, haben wir glaube ich, das ist auch noch gar nicht erwähnt. Gut, dass wir das jetzt mal anpicken. Ist ja auch einfach Wert speichern. Und wenn ich jetzt einfach nur Wert irgendwo speichern kann, dadurch, da ich ihn wirklich irgendwo hinlege, und das war's dann, das ist schon relativ unattraktiv.
Aber ist es nicht auch ein Hemmnis für die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung, wenn ich Geld liegen lasse, anstatt das Geld zu benutzen?
Nee, eher im Gegenteil eigentlich, weil das Geld, was irgendwo liegen bleibt, wird von den Banken dann wieder an kleine Start-up-Firmen...
Aber ist es nicht, dass es stillgehasst wird?
Nein, nein, nein, nur wenn es der Bank auch gibt, wenn es irgendwo liegen lässt.
Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel 1000 Mark sparst, dann ist das irgendwie ein schöner Betrag, den kannst du irgendwie zu deiner... Dann könntest du ihn natürlich auch direkt irgendwo anlegen, was ja jetzt mit diesen ganzen Day-Traden und Internet und Banking... Dings hier, Aktienhandel, auch relativ modern gerade ist, wo eine Menge Kapitalisierung nicht mehr über den Umweg der Banken läuft, sondern direkt halt durch Aktien-Ausgabe und ist dann direkt zu den Firmen. Da passiert im Prinzip das, da gibst du halt die 1000 Mark mehr oder weniger mit halt so ein paar Prozent an die damit... an vermittelten, damit verbundenen Leute direkt an die Firma oder zumindest an andere, die mit diesen Aktien spekulieren, weil die Firma kriegt ja nur das Geld vom Epo, also vom, also vom... Ja, das stimmt nicht so ganz, weil das ist ja nur das Erste. Du kannst ja auch hinterher nochmal irgendwie schnell Millionen Aktien raustun oder sie splitten, wie irgendwelche amerikanischen Firmen 1000 Mark und damit kann eine Firma schon ein bisschen was anfangen und 100 Leute zusammen kriegen, die jeweils 1000 Mark geben, ist halt ein relativ mühseliges Gewerbe. Von daher ist irgendwie so eben die Sparerquote und was davon einem als Kredite rausgegeben wird, schon nicht immer interessant.
Joa, drei Minuten haben wir noch. Möcht noch jemand nen Fazit sagen vielleicht? Benutzt eCash.
Benutzt eCash und spendet damit dem CCC.
Kann ich damit denn auch bei Amazon Bücher kaufen und die postlagernd irgendwo hinschicken lassen?
Ähm, hoffentlich bald.
Man kann natürlich auch relativ einfach selber einen eCash Shop aufsetzen. Also es ist nicht so wie bei Kreditkarten, dass man dann irgendwelche dicken Formulare ausfüllen muss und ähm, wie viel man dann haftet und gebühren geringe Beträge. Das heißt gerade für Leute wie zum Beispiel Musiker oder vielleicht auch Leute, die Bilder machen, Texte schreiben und so weiter und so fort ist es sehr attraktiv, selber einen solchen Shop aufzusetzen.
Ja und man kann das Geld halt auch privat empfangen. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel jemandem einen Gefallen getan hab, ich hab ihm zum Beispiel ein Buch aus der nächsten Bücherei mitgebracht irgendwie, weil das gibt's ja auch noch irgendwie so im realen Leben. Und dem schulde ich jetzt 30 Mark, weil er mir das halt oder er schuldet mir 30 Mark, weil ich ihm das mitgebracht habe, dann kann er mir das auch irgendwie schnell als E-Cash Zahlung in eine E-Mail packen und irgendwie von Mensch zu Mensch, statt irgendwie von Mensch zu Händler, was halt bei vielen anderen Systemen auch Hauptfeature ist.
Das ist wirklich das schöne Ding einfach. Ich kann im Internet über Kontinente einfach, hier schick ich Blut in die E-Mail, da ist schon auch tatsächlich Geld drin.
www.icash.de www.icash.de Ach so, wir wollten ja noch WU-Card heißt das Ganze.
Wir wollten ja noch erläutern, wie das ist mit den Strukturen der Phonoindustrie, wenn man International CDs kauft.
Ich glaube, das schaffen wir nicht mehr. Das sollten wir glaube, das ist zwei Minuten.
Also ich fände als Fazit benutzt Icash schon nicht schlecht, aber macht eure eigenen Icash-Shops als Fazit noch ein bisschen besser.
Na ja und, eure Privatsphäre ist euer Grundrecht.
Ja und halt nicht nur Empfänger sein, nicht nur irgendwie Fernbedienung, sondern selber machen. Im Sinne von wenn ich einen sehr eigenen Shop mache, dann mach ich da ein bisschen HTML, dann werde ich vom Empfänger auch zum Sender irgendwie benutzen, auch den Rückkannal, den mir das Internet bietet im Vergleich zu Radio und Fernseher und jetzt werde ich hier immer ganz voll vermittelt sein.
Fazit Schluss, das fand ich schöner, muss ich sagen.
Na gut, wir gehen jetzt nach Hause. Tschüss.
Am letzten Mittwoch im April und hier gibt es jetzt sofort den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf Schlafgut.